Hey Kian! Hey Henrik!
Wir sitzen gerade auf dem Mobile Camp im ASCII, haben uns eingeschlossen.
Das ist so eine Konferenz, die findet jedes Jahr statt bei uns in der Fakultät Informatik.
Ist eigentlich ziemlich witzig.
Ja, ich glaube, ich komme eigentlich immer bloß wegen der Community-Arbeit hierher.
Ja, also Leute kennenlernen und schauen, was so geht.
Für Leute sind hier so 150?
Ja.
Ganz viel so App- und Web-Entwickler.
Und Marketing und Anwälte dies Jahr sogar.
Anwälte?
Ein paar Team-Anwälte sind, glaube ich, mit Sponsoren.
Ganz Team-Anwälte, muss ich Angst haben?
Nee, die sind als Freunde hier.
Okay.
We come in peace, sozusagen.
Das haben sie nicht gesagt, aber ich gehe davon aus.
Hast du dir ein paar Vorträge reingezogen?
Du sagst gerade irgendwas von wegen Paperless live?
Die Idee ist, papierfrei zu leben.
Genau, da habe ich mich kaum mit reingesetzt,
weil ich das generell auch schon seit quasi Jahren mache
und beibehalten möchte und wollte auch mal ein bisschen Input abholen,
was für Tools andere so nutzen und wie die das eben vorantreiben.
Aber apropos papierfrei, wenn ich mir stattdessen angucke,
die Leute vom Mobilcamp haben für die ganzen Besucher Pizza organisiert.
Wir hatten ja eine anderthalb Meter hohen Stapel an Pizzakartons.
Der Pizza Tower ist auch so eine Tradition geworden hier,
mit dem leeren Pizzakartons dann einen möglichst großen Turm zu bauen.
Hältst Vorträge darüber, papierfrei zu leben
und dann stellst du dir solche Pizzakartonstapel her.
Das stimmt.
Man sollte eigentlich Pizza in Pizzakartons ausliefern,
also Pizzakartons, die aus Pizza sind.
Oh.
Ich glaube, das nennt sich dann Calzone.
Die Calzone einfach so stapeln.
Gute Idee.
Also es gab auch noch viel Papier auf diesen Stehtischen,
die hier rumstehen.
Ja, ein bisschen Werbung.
Das Schöne am Mobile Camp ist halt, dass es eine komplett kostenlose Sache ist.
Und das ist halt komplett durch Sponsoren mitfinanziert.
Das macht es sehr angenehm, hier ehrlich immer wieder hinzukommen.
Für uns ist es quasi eh vor Ort.
Aber es ist eben auch keine Teilnahmegebühr.
Es gibt Essen umsonst, es gibt dir so ein T-Shirt einfach so geschenkt.
Und ja, man sieht bekannte Gesichter, aber auch immer wieder viele neue.
Und die Talks sind eigentlich immer ganz cool.
Also es gibt ein T-Shirt, wenn du dich offiziell angemeldet hast,
was ich irgendwie jedes Jahr vergesse.
Du kommst ja immer so.
Ich denke mir immer, naja, es ist ja kostenlösisch, da gehst du hin.
Und dann laufen irgendwie alle mit so einem T-Shirt und so einem Badge rum.
Und ich so, stimmt, da hätte ich mich wahrscheinlich für anmelden müssen.
Darf ich trotzdem mitmachen?
Da wird niemand ausgeschlossen hier.
Meine Fakultät ist ja eh zugänglich.
So ist es ja nicht.
Also letztes Jahr hat mich ein bisschen schockiert,
dass es so, es gibt ja tonnenweise,
das wollte ich gerade erzählen,
auf diesen Tischen Flyer für alles Mögliche.
Sowas wie,
Why do Java programmers need glasses?
Because they don't see sharp.
Letztes Jahr gab es Flyer für die PHP User Group.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Ich erinnere mich. Bist du da mal hingegangen?
Nee, da traue ich mich auch nicht hin.
Dass P.A.P. noch nehmt.
Ein Wunder.
Genau.
Dieses Jahr habe ich irgendwie nicht so ganz
Schlimmes gesehen, bis auf dieses C-Sharp-Dings.
Das war ja ein schlechter Witz.
Aber die ist ja auch bloß Werbung
in irgendeiner Flyer für eine Firma gewesen.
Von wegen kommt es zu uns.
Ich habe wieder vergessen, von wem das war.
Bisschen grenzwertig finde ich die Werbung
auf den Kolle-Mate-Flaschen oder auf den
Mate-Flaschen, die sie hier hinstellen.
Keine Kolle-Mate.
Ja, dieses Mal ist es Club Marte und da haben sie einfach über das Label einen großen Aufkleber drüber geklebt.
Ich sage jetzt aber nicht, wer das gemacht hat.
Und hier erkennt man jetzt noch, weil Club Marte Flaschen zwei Labels haben.
Erkennst du irgendwie noch, was es ursprünglich mal war?
Aber es ist schon ein bisschen grenzwertig, das Label einfach.
Es ist schon ein bisschen hart.
Letztes Jahr haben sie es über Colle Marte drüber geklebt.
Colle Marte hat nur ein Label, da haben sie das Originallabel komplett zugeklebt.
Da wusstest du hinterher nicht mehr, was das für ein Getränk ist, was du dazu nimmst.
Du hast es auch drunter nicht mehr lesen können.
Also es war irgendwie so ein fetter Venue-Aufkleber,
der einmal rundherum ging.
Das war komplett dann verschleiernd.
Okay, das ist ja echt komisch.
Hast du sonst noch irgendwelche Talk-Trip-Besuche gehabt hier?
Oh, gerade eben der Sebastian Mielke hat ja einen Vortrag
über die Mystifying Neural Networks gehalten.
Der war eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Das ist ein schöner 10.000-Feed-Overview
über neuronale Netzwerke, über Machine Learning.
war eigentlich, fand ich
ziemlich gut aufgearbeitet, gerade für Leute, die
noch nie reingeguckt haben.
An einer Stelle hat er sich so ein bisschen hinreißen
lassen, zu sagen, dafür habe ich jetzt
gerade keine Folie, ich mache mal fix was an der Tafel.
Dann hat er sich irgendwie fünf Minuten
an der Tafel mit irgendwelchen
Ableitungen hingehalten.
Das hat dann wahrscheinlich nochmal so für ein paar
Gena gesorgt und die Leute so ein bisschen
abgeschreckt. Aber so allein für den Überblick,
warum macht man
neuronale Netze, was sind da,
was ist ein Layer bei sowas,
was ist Backpropagation,
was ist ein Feature,
ist eigentlich schon
ein schöner Einstieg gewesen für Leute,
die gerade erst damit anfangen und nie, bis davon gehört haben.
Finde ich auch, es war nett generell.
Als jemand, der weniger Erfahrung auf dem Gebiet hat,
fand ich das sehr
angenehm, den Overview zu hören,
dass es eigentlich kein creepy Kram ist
und alles Simpelste, einfachste,
Mathematik, bloß stark abstrahiert
und weitergeführt.
Es war nett zu hören.
Genau. Ansonsten war ich
vorhin in einem Vortrag von Ben über
React Native.
Das war auch mal ganz spannend, weil ich gerade
überlege, dieses kleine Webspiel, was ich
irgendwie vor fünf Jahren mal gebaut habe,
mit CoffeeScript,
mal auf modernere Beine zu stellen
und irgendwie mein
Make-File und
meine Git-Sub-Module durch anständige
NPM
beziehungsweise Jahr-Dependencies zu ersetzen
und das irgendwie mal in
TypeScript zu portieren. Ich glaube, das werde ich nicht machen.
da bin ich halt gerade auf der Suche nach einem
Framework, in das ich das einbetten kann
da habe ich überlegt, ob ich entweder Angular oder
React nehme, aber ich bin da überhaupt
kein Web-Entwickler, dementsprechend
React sieht schon ein bisschen schöner aus
aber er hat einen Vortrag über React Native
gehalten, was mir in dem Zusammenhang
aufgefallen ist, dass es nicht nur
React und React Native gibt
sondern auch noch React Native
Web. Ich kann mir das noch nicht wirklich
was darunter vorstellen
ich schreibe da ja was gibt, um keine native UI
sondern um noch mehr JavaScript abzubringen.
Endeffekt ist React ein Web-Framework,
mit dem beschreibst du halt
Functional Reactive Programming,
deine Oberfläche.
Die Leute von Facebook haben sich auch mal gedacht,
gut, damit bauen wir jetzt einfach native Anwendungen
und haben da noch ein bisschen Rapper und Übersetzungs-Code rumgebaut.
Dann konnte man plötzlich mit einem sehr ähnlichen Framework
native Anwendungen für iOS und Android bauen.
Und irgendwann haben sich die Leute gedacht,
naja, eigentlich ist es ganz schön, wie du in React Native deine Apps beschreibst.
Du schreibst dann nämlich keine HTML-Text mehr dazwischen,
sondern sowas wie Button und Text und wesentlich abstraktere Sachen.
Das möchte ich jetzt eigentlich auch im Web machen.
Dementsprechend gibt es React Native Web.
Interessant.
Du kannst also Web-Apps mit React und React Native Web schreiben.
Das ist ein bisschen abgefahren.
Aber ich habe mich nicht intensiver damit beschäftigt.
Also die Technologie an sich auf der nativen Seite finde ich interessant, weil viele Leute wollen halt JavaScript schreiben.
Ich persönlich will es nicht, aber viele wollen das, weil es sehr angenommen ist für die.
Und das Problem, das man halt wirklich immer hatte, ist die ekelhafte Web-UI.
Und das spürt man halt auch wirklich, wenn man eine App vor sich hat, die halt nicht nativ ist.
Und native UI fühlt sich so bedeutend viel angenehmer, flüssiger und sauberer an.
Das macht einen riesen Unterschied.
Aber JavaScript für UI-Entwicklung ist eigentlich naheliegend.
Erstens, es wurde dafür erfunden.
Quasi, ja.
Dieses ganze reaktive
Event-Loop-basierte
Konzept ist auch
für UI-Entwicklung
extrem naheliegend,
weil du ja nie genau weißt,
was der Nutzer als nächstes macht.
Also hast du keine linearen Abläufe, also musst du auf Events
reagieren.
Andere UI-Frameworks,
die schon älter sind und vorher nicht
auf JavaScript basiert haben,
bauen plötzlich ähnliche Konzepte ein.
Ich habe ja letztens von
fangen wir mal an mit sowas wie
Qt, die plötzlich ihre eigene
JavaScript-artige
Sprache erfinden, um
ähnliche User-Interfaces
zu bauen. Und dann gibt es
neuere Frameworks, wie zum Beispiel Realm,
was auch auf
Futures und auf Events
basiert und versucht,
möglichst reaktiv. Das ist natürlich
an Elm dann angelegt.
Ah, der Heidernahme.
Ja, das war
Tag 2. Gestern waren auch
ein paar coole Vorträge.
Ich saß in allem über
Reverse Engineering iOS Apps.
Wer hat den denn gehalten? Ich glaube, das warst du.
Hat ziemlich gut.
Hat Spaß gemacht. Ich bin ja das
vierte Mal jetzt hier auf MobileCamp und wollte mal ein bisschen
was über was quatschen, was mir auch mal mit dem Herzen liegt,
was ich zumindest Spaß mit habe.
Und habe mal das Thema Reverse Engineering
iOS Apps aufgegriffen und habe da mal
auch kurz demonstriert, was ich
da so machen kann, was wir mir für Möglichkeiten bieten.
Habe das spannendste Thema auslassen
müssen aus Tech-Gründen.
und habe erstmal bloß gezeigt,
wie man seine App
oder eine fremde App eher
man in the middle und da Daten einschiebt
und dann auch mal,
wie man auf dem Jailbreaking-Gerät sich mit einem
Ripple in die App reinsetzen kann und da
random Code injecten kann und ausführen kann.
Das geht aber hauptsächlich, weil die
weil diese Runtime
von Objective-C auf
Nachrichten basiert, die ich abfangen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, also das ist natürlich
die Architektur, die das an der Stelle wirklich
erlaubt. Wenn wir irgendwann mal
das komplett umkrempeln und anders
machen, dann geht es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so einfach, aber es gibt
immer Wege, sowas zu tun. Also Call Injection
klappt immer halt manchmal ein bisschen anders
vom Ansatz her.
Hier war es ja so, dass du natürlich die originalen Namen
von den Methoden und Objekten, wo jeder
verwenden konntest, oder? Das stimmt, ja.
Wird das so ähnlich noch funktionieren,
wenn deine Anwendung dann komplett ins Wilt geschrieben ist?
Da wurde es doch wahrscheinlich alles wegkompiliert.
Das hängt natürlich
davon ab, was der Compiler damit tut.
Also warte mal, wenn ich jetzt, würdest du das heißen,
dass wenn ich Strings auf eine
iOS-App, die in Objective-C
geschrieben ist, schmeiße,
dass ich dann die ganzen Methoden und Funktionsnamen
und Objektnamen noch sehe.
Das ist ja recht spannend.
Ich habe den Talk quasi
leider am Vortag vorbereitet.
Ja, du hast dich nicht an die
Regeln aus dem letzten Bike-Chat gehalten.
Don't re-apologize for a lack of information.
Ich habe das auch natürlich mitgesagt im Talk. Ich werde diesen Talk
aber nochmal halten mit bedeutend besserer Vorbereitung
beim nächsten Cocoa-Heads-Meetup.
Da wird er dann noch aufgezeichnet.
da wird der Alex Witkowski
von den Developers, wo der Talk
wahrscheinlich gehalten wird, meinte er auch,
er will ihn sogar live streamen.
Der läuft ja auch von Ocho,
das steht da.
Das wäre ganz cool, die Aufzeichnung
zumindest davon zu haben,
im Nachhinein uns auch mal irgendwo mit zu posten,
aber ich werde mich auch
darüber ein bisschen mehr auseinandersetzen.
Muss ich gestehen, von manchen, die gerade tiefer
gehenden Dinge nicht ganz so viel Ahnung, wo ich mehr Ahnung
von habe, ist wirklich der Man-in-the-Middle-Attack-Teil,
weil das auch einfach mega viel Spaß macht
und super, super einfach ist.
Also Live-Debugging ist eigentlich super geil.
Das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund,
warum ich schon noch gerne Sachen in die Havingskript
vor mir habe.
Ich habe jetzt auf Arbeit,
sollte ich mich mal eine Codebase von Kollegen
aus den USA einlesen und das mal durchspielen.
Und das macht viel mehr Spaß,
wenn du dich da durchdebugst
und da irgendwie an irgendeiner Stelle einfach mal sagst,
okay, ab hier möchte ich jetzt mal live weiterhacken können
und Sachen bearbeiten können, um zu sehen, was passiert.
Das geht an solchen Stellen wesentlich
schöner, als wenn du eine Anwendung hast, die in einer
kompletten nativen Sprache geschrieben ist.
Sobald du irgendwie was in C++,
Rust, Swift hast, ich weiß nicht, wie es in Swift ist,
aber bei den anderen Sprachen kannst du
ja nicht mal eben sagen,
da kannst du dich zwar mit einem Compiler an einer bestimmten Stelle setzen,
aber da kannst du nicht mit den gleichen Mitteln von der ursprünglichen
Sprache da drin
live weiterarbeiten. Das ist nicht so, als ob ich
im GDB oder
im LLDB dann plötzlich eine Rust-Funktion
aufrufen kann.
So, oder?
Das ist so der Hauptunterschied
zwischen kompiliert und interpretiert, oder?
Ja, ja.
Also ich habe noch den Soß zur Hand.
Ich habe noch Informationen.
Ich glaube, ich habe kaum etwas falsch gesagt.
Hoffentlich.
Aber vielleicht können die Bagger das sogar.
Und ich kann das zu wenig.
Wir sagen, die Bagger drücken uns eh wieder
im gefährlichen Halbwissenbereich.
Warum heißt der Podcast eigentlich nicht gefährliches Halbwissen?
Sollten wir generell mal umbenennen.
Nee, machen wir mal lieber nicht,
weil wir haben gerade für 60 Euro
Akronomisier.bar gekauft.
Demain war erstaunlich teuer.
Also das wäre so das,
wenn ihr uns immer noch hört,
jetzt mittlerweile bei Folge 5
und ihr habt uns mittlerweile
auf unserer neuen Website gefunden
und euch gefällt das,
dann könnt ihr uns ja gerne mal
ein bisschen was zukommen lassen,
damit wir diese Demain dann
in einem Jahr auch wieder verlängern können.
Ach, wir fahren einfach irgendwann mal
ein bisschen Flatter und Patreon noch zusätzlich auf,
ohne da viel dahinter zu verstecken.
Flatter, machen das Leute überhaupt noch?
Mikrowelle OS, was wir nutzen wollen
zum Diplom der Seite, hat sogar
Flatter Support eingebaut.
Also ich weiß, ich habe dieses Spiel, von dem ich vorhin geredet habe,
Naubino.
Ja, es ist ein kleines Web-Spiel, was irgendwie
in fünf Iterationen existiert,
das ich irgendwie am Anfang des Studiums
mal in
Flash gebaut habe, dafür aber
in, wie hieß dieses,
in Processing
geprototypt habe.
spannend. Und das haben wir dann in
JavaScript oder CoffeeScript nochmal
neu gebaut, oder ich und Gilbert hat es
in Python nochmal neu gebaut und noch
irgendjemand hat es nochmal mit Qt neu
gebaut, wo ich das nie gesehen habe. Findet ihr übrigens
auf naubino.de. Und da wollte ich gerade
sagen, da habe ich mir so einen
Flatter-Knopf hingesetzt. Hat der
schon mal jemand drauf gedrückt? Da hat schon mal jemand drauf
gedrückt. Guck mal, da steht eins.
Da hat genau einer schon mal
drauf gedrückt. Also das ist
leider, ich habe diesen Flatter-Account
und ich habe dieses eine Ding mal
ich mache das ja auch nicht für Blogposts
oder irgendwelche Sachen. Ich könnte das vielleicht
mal in so GitHub-Repos
reintun. Das wäre vielleicht
möglich, oder? Da gibt es doch dieses GitPay
oder wie das heißt extra. Zumindest hat bei
Naubino hat mal
einer was geflattert. Das
habe ich dann umgerechnet bekommen. Das ist ja immer
dann ein Anteil von den
zwei Euro, die die Person
im Monat da eingezahlt hat.
Das ist ein beliebiger Betrag sogar, den man da haben konnte?
Das Konzept
funktioniert so, dass du
sagst, ich investiere pro Monat
so und so viel Geld, sagen wir,
Standardbetrag ist glaube ich 2 Euro
und dann flatter ich so viel ich will.
Das heißt, ich drücke auf Flatter-Button
bei Blogpost und sonst wo.
Genau, wenn irgendwas gefällt, dann flatter ich das
und das heißt,
am Ende des Monats werden glaube ich meine
ganzen Flatters
zusammengezählt und
dann wird mein Betrag durch die Anzahl
meiner Klicks
geteilt und dann kriegen die Leute
dann Anteil, ich meine, da zwei Euro.
So, irgendjemand hatte
einmal
auf den Flatter-Button gedrückt bei naubino.de,
deswegen hat dieses Spiel,
obwohl es, also, ich habe
von Leuten gehört, die das den ganzen Abend lang gespielt haben,
probiere es aus, es hat einen Flatter
und das ist jetzt 37 Cent wert
und das ist weit unter dem Betrag,
den du mindestens erreichen musst, um das Geld
auch auszutauschen zu bekommen.
Das ist erstaunlich viel.
Ja, weil die Person wahrscheinlich bloß sechs Sachen
in dem Monat geflattert hat.
Sicherlich. Ich habe mal eine Zeit lang Flatter-Mails fast, also locker so zwei, drei die Woche bekommen, weil einer meiner Twitter-Follower hatte sich wohl mit seinem Client automatisch was reingebaut, was bei jedes Mal, wenn er einen Tweet gestarrt oder irgendwie tweetet hat, dann hat er diesen Tweet geflattert und den Arthur dann eben benachrichtigt.
Und ich habe durch diese,
ich glaube, ich habe letztens mal noch reingeschaut,
ich glaube, das waren insgesamt 20, 30 Mails,
insgesamt 24 Cent
erwirtschaftet, die ich mir natürlich auch seit,
das ist älter als
fünf Jahre oder so,
die ich mir natürlich nicht aussage. Also wäre ich auch nicht
da interessiert, aber ich finde es einfach witzig,
dass es halt immer noch lebt. Das ist halt auch schon
ein gewisses Alter erreicht. Das ist aber die Frage, die ich mir gerade
stelle, der Typ, der das
erfunden hat, der,
wie hieß er, der ist so einer bitteren
Typ, Pirate Bay
Typ, wie hieß der Peter Sünde?
Der hat Flatter geschickt worden? Der hatte Flatter erfunden.
Echt? Okay, das musste ich eigentlich. Der ist da glaube ich mittlerweile
auch raus. Der saß ja auch ein paar Jahre im Knast
und ich weiß
nicht, ob Flatter noch so aktiv
genutzt wird. Ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass es
so ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten ist. Ja, das war
damals, hat das wirklich echt einen starken Push bekommen,
gerade so in der Podcast und Blogging zu haben. Ja, ich habe ja den Eindruck
gehabt, dass Tim Pridloff
fast ausschließlich von Flatter gelebt
hat ein paar Jahre lang, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch
geht. Da gab es halt plötzlich dann sowas wie Patreon
wo du einfach einen Pledge machst
und dann
Podcaster oder andere
schaffende
Producer
dann einfach kontinuierlich
unterstützt.
Patreon ist auch so das, was gerade so
das absolut Populäre ist.
Du kannst ja Zahlen pro
immer die Person created, also bei uns
halt pro Folge quasi, wäre so die Idee
oder pro Monat
und du kannst da halt verschiedene Pledge-Levels
wie bei Kickstarter einrichten und dann halt
zahlen, keine Ahnung. Du zahlst einen Dollar pro Folge
und dann ist das halt so, oder du zahlst
20 Dollar im Monat, wenn du halt ultra kraft bist.
Aber sowas gibt es eigentlich bei
Flatter auch, da kannst du auch Subscriptions
machen. Genau, nur das vorausgesehen,
aber es ist nicht populär geworden, gefühlt.
Also Flatter-Button sieht man oft noch im Netz, aber ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie viele Leute das technisch nutzen. Also ich habe schon
lange, ich benutze selber, muss ich sagen,
schon eine Weile nicht mehr. Ich habe das
zwei, dreimal aufgefüllt.
Einmal. Einzigst mal.
Ja, dann habe ich das alles verklickt, quasi.
Dann ist mir irgendwann aufgefallen, dass ich
das, was ich
verklicke, in keinem Verhältnis
steht zu dem, was ich da reinzahle.
Dass wahrscheinlich jeder Flatter von mir
so ein paar Euro wert war.
Das ist stark.
Und das müsste man eigentlich
mal wieder ein bisschen
in Erinnerung rufen.
Wir können es ja mal auf unsere Seite packen.
Mal schauen, ob irgendeiner unserer toll wunderbaren
Zuhörer einen Flatter-Account noch hat.
Mal schauen, wie viel Flatter ein Nowi nur jetzt gibt.
Also spiel zwar durch, das ist definitiv
technisch von der Oberfläche noch
verbesserungswürdig. Ich hätte es gerne nicht mehr
in Coffees grüppelt, weil wenn diese
Codebase, wenn du dir das drei Jahre später nochmal
anguckst, dann ist es einfach leider
nicht so übersichtlich, wie ich gedacht hatte, dass es übersichtlich wäre.
Aber das muss doch so sein. Der Grundsatz
ist doch, wenn du zwei Wochen, nachdem du Code
geschrieben hast, nochmal drüber schaust und dich nicht dafür schämst,
dann machst du was falsch.
Ich dachte, dann machst du was richtig.
So könnte man es natürlich auch
sehen, aber grundsätzlich gerade, wenn du
Jahre alten Code von dir anschaust,
dann ist das immer komisch
und uralt.
Ich habe vorhin bei diesem React Native
Code Vortrag
habe ich ein bisschen rumgebrowsed
nach Game Development
mit React
und so einen
Blogpost of Medium gefunden und da gab es
auch eine Metrik für
The only valid measurement of Code Quality
ist WTFs per Minute.
Und da hast du quasi
Good Code ist so zwei
WTFs pro Minute
und dann gibt es bad Code.
Da steht WTF,
WTF is this shit, WTF dude.
What the fuck?
Ja, also wenn, je häufiger
du es quasi an der Stirn
klatschen hörst beim Code Review,
das ist die nette Metrik.
Gefällt mir.
Soll man sich merken.
Kann man das irgendwie automatisch quantifizieren?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich stehe da so ein bisschen Code Beispiel. Ich mache mal einen kleinen Sprung.
import myfood from
my-food. Das ist hier so ein bisschen
Syntax aus der neuen ES6
Modul.
Syntax.
Du hast ja vorher bei JavaScript
geschrieben.
Require.
Genau.
Var require oder mittlerweile
const require
something
ist gleich und dann String, was dann der Name
von deinem Modul ist und von einer anderen Datei
ist oder sowas.
und
das wurde jetzt ersetzt durch
Import oder beziehungsweise
ist jetzt erweitert worden im Import, man kann ja immer
das alte Zeug immer auch noch machen,
aber was ich irgendwie für eine total schlechte
Idee halte, sind Default
Exports und Default Imports bei
Default Export gibt es bloß.
Die automatisch von Haus aus exportiert werden?
Nee, du kannst
ein, also du kannst es
ja quasi so machen, dass du ein Modul hast
und da hast du zwei Klassen drin, Klasse
Hund und Klasse Katze
und dann sagst du Export
Hund, also du schreibst Export vor Hund
und dann schreibst du Export vor Katze.
Und jemand anders, der deine Modul Haustiere
importiert, sagt dann
Import und dann Curly Braces für das
Destructuring Hund, Katze from
Haustiere.
Ah, der muss halt wissen, was du alles exportest.
Genau, und das wird aber, du kannst
das halt namentlich vorne hinschreiben
und das Schöne an dieser Klammer-Syntax ist, dass
durch das Destructuring wird halt
noch validiert, dass das wirklich die gleichen
Namen hat. Bei Default, Import
kannst du sagen, ich schreibe Default Export
für irgendwas davor.
Und dann kann jemand anders hingehen
und sagen, Import
irgendwas from
Haustiere. Dann kriegt er halt diesen
Default Export. Dann muss er den richtigen Identifier natürlich gehen.
Nein. Das heißt dann
so.
Du kannst dann hinschreiben, Import something
from Haustiere und was auch immer
das Default Export
von Haustiere ist, heißt dann bei mir something.
Okay.
Und das hast du mir schon beim Lesen von Code-Basen tierisch auf die Füße gefallen,
weil ich mich gewundert habe, das ist doch das und der benutzt das.
Aber hier heißt es so, ach, das ist das Default Export.
Die haben einen anderen Namen angegeben oder einen slightly anderen Namen.
Und ich wundere dich, warum das gleiche Ding an drei Stellen unterschiedlich heißt.
Das war eindeutig ein Code-Smell, oder?
Das ist ein ganz schönes Anti-Pattern.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Leute sich bei Default-Exports gedacht haben,
aber es führt eigentlich nur zu solchen Sachen.
Das ist ein bisschen convenient,
aber eigentlich führt es hauptsächlich dazu,
dass du Module importierst, die woanders heißen.
Das macht es sehr schlecht lesbar.
Guck mal, der läuft Mr. Buckman, der läuft da draußen wieder rum.
Gar kein Klimascheu.
Wir sitzen hier hinter der Fensterscheibe vom ASCII,
haben uns eingeschlossen, haben einen On-Air-Zettel an die Scheibe geklebt
und beobachten jetzt so ein bisschen
die Leute. Wir haben doch, glaube ich, schon mal drüber
geredet, dass
Nerds in bestimmte Kategorien fallen.
Ich glaube, das war eine Tornulnummer, ja.
Ja, dass auf einem Kongress Leute rumlaufen,
wo du denkst, ach, das ist der, aber
so, und das ist, keine Ahnung, auf dem letzten
Kongress ist mir übelst einer aufgefallen,
den ich mehrmals gesehen habe, der
sah aus wie Steiger, wie aus dem Groß.
Aber übelst.
Also so, dass ich den schon am Anfang
das erste Mal fast gegrüßt hätte und jedes Mal mit dem Augenwinkel
gesehen habe, habe ich mir gedacht, ach Mensch, ach nee,
dann doch nicht.
Und hier läuft einer rum, der sieht aus
wie einer der Charaktere aus
Silicon Valley.
Oh ja, du darfst bitte nichts
darüber erzählen, ich habe die neue Folge immer noch nicht geguckt.
Mach das bitte, es geht
großartig weiter. Also es gibt
eine neue Folge Silicon Valley,
es gibt eine neue Folge Rick and Morty,
aber die zweite, die Staffel
geht noch nicht offiziell weiter, oder?
Ich glaube nicht, also die Folge kam ja
raus, am 1. April quasi,
aber seitdem halt auch nichts weiter.
Ich glaube, die haben jetzt eine Folge gedumpt
im Internet, aber
in Weitem erst nichts passiert seitdem.
Poor Rick and Morty.
Du hast da was Schönes entdeckt.
Ja, ich habe gestern mal,
nachdem wir uns über Zeugs
unterhalten haben, saßen wir hier
und überlegt, dass ich doch gerne ein Fidget Cube
hätte. Dann war ich
auf Amazon
und habe einfach mal
so einen Stoß Fidget Cubes bestellt.
die kostet doch bloß, je nachdem wo du es bestellst,
zwei Euro. Dann ist mir irgendwie eine Seite
eingefallen, dann hat mich irgendwas weitergeleitet
auf ThinkGeek und dann ist mir,
da gab es lustigen Scheiß.
Und dann ist mir die Seite
This is why I'm broke
wieder eingefallen.
This is why I'm broke ist echt eine herrliche
Auflistung von Scheiß, den man kaufen kann.
Ich werde gar nicht drauf gehen, ich bin sehr anfällig,
mir Scheiß zu bestellen. Ich glaube, ich hätte dir
davon nicht erzählen sollen. Aber
da gab es
Autovervollstehung von Seiten,
die mit this anfangen.
Das ist immer nicht...
This week in Rust.
This is Net Neutrality.
Ich gebe hier in meinem Browser this ein und kriege irgendwas
vervollständiges. Das ist es nicht.
This week in Rust. Nein, this is.
Und dann kommt this is Net Neutrality.
This is why I'm
broke.com
Da war erstaunlich viel
Not Safe for Work dabei.
Aber ganz oben ist er.
ganz oben ein Plumbus.
Richtig, richtig geil. Das müssen wir noch verlinken.
Wir verlinken auch die WickedModi-Zähne nochmal,
falls ihr jemand vergessen haben sollte.
Die läuft ja quasi im Hintergrund.
Du kannst dir für 50 Dollar einen Plumbus bestellen.
Das war so ein herrlicher Schrottartikel.
Der schon in WickedModi ein beworbener
Schrottartikel war.
Das ist da ein ganz normales Haushaltsgerät.
Da hängt das ja in der Küche
an so einem Halter, so einem Plumbus-Halter.
Aber ich meine, hier gibt es schöne Sachen,
so was wie die NES Classic Mini,
diese Neuauflage von dem Ding.
Aber die haben sie wieder eingestellt.
Die wollten damit bloß alte Hardware loswerden.
Echt?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich die gängige Theorie.
Das Ding war kurz verkauft und es war wirklich für eine Idee
auf Hacker News, dass die das bloß kurz
aufgefahren haben, damit die von einem
ihrer Partsmanufacturer richtig Menge
an End-of-Life-Hardware
loswerden konnten für den Parts-Kram.
Und das haben sie jetzt komplett aufgebraucht,
weil die Nachfrage verständlicherweise
gigantisch war. Und dann haben sie wieder eingeschwacht.
Also das Projekt ist vorbei.
Schade, ich dachte, ich war da kurz dafür, mir eine zu holen.
Die hat auch bloß 75 Euro gekostet.
Aber das ist ja wirklich quasi ein Pi da drin,
wo ein Emulator draufläuft.
Es geht halt um die Hülle eher.
Also bei Golem haben sie es getestet.
Das Ding ist von der Performance her an manchen Stellen
ein bisschen der alten NES hinterher gewesen.
Echt hinterher?
Ja, ja. Also manchmal war es ein bisschen laggy.
Das ist doch eine NES.
Das emuliert man doch heutzutage richtig sauber weg.
Ja, aber wenn es bloß
wenn es auf einem Pi läuft,
wenn du es nicht 100% optimiert hast.
Aber ich gehe mal hier ein paar Sachen durch.
Also ein paar sind sinnvoll.
Es gibt hier zum Beispiel Vintage World Map Wallpaper.
Sieht schick aus.
In Anführungsstrichen sinnvoll.
Ja, das ist schon was, wo man sich denken könnte,
ja, ist irgendwie schick und geschmackvoll meinetwegen.
Oder so ein Bad Fan.
Das ist einfach so ein Teil, was dir unter die Bettdecke pustet.
Ah, Kühnluft.
Oder halt Fidget Cubes.
Und dann gibt es aber auch so richtig bescheuerten Mist,
wo du dir denkst, what?
Penis-shaped Lipstick.
Klar, braucht man auch daheim.
Dragon Sex Cannon.
Das ist halt das Internet.
Ein Buch, Diseases Caused by Masturbation.
Das sieht eigentlich fast putzig aus, bis du es zu Ende liest.
Foxtail, Buttplug.
Ja klar, willkommen im Internet, Henrik.
Das ist jetzt nicht groß was Neues.
Das ist vorhanden.
Ich meine bloß, mich hat es gewundert, dass hier so viel
sexuelles Zeugs dabei ist.
Was ein bisschen fies ist, ist das Annoying Sound
Torture Device. Das ist so ein kleines Ding, das hat
die Größe von einem Fidget Cube
und das Bild zeigt, wie jemand das jemand anders unter
den Tisch klebt. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch etwas, was einfach
hochfrequent fiebt.
Der Klassiker ist ja so ein Ding, dass du dann in deinem
Office unter die Deckenpanels halt so ein Ding
drauflegst und dann deine Kollegen
somit richtig fertig machst.
Aber es gibt halt so viel
wunderschönen Scheiße, wenn man Internet bestellen kann.
Ich glaube, du willst gerade noch dein Lieblingsteil vorstellen.
Embarrassing Prank
Shipping Box. Einfach bloß
eine Shipping Box
für andere Sachen. Vielleicht stellst du es auch
einem Nachbarn vor die Tür. Ich weiß es nicht.
Und da steht
bigassbildos.com
drauf.
Schön.
Das erinnert mich an diese Seite, die es vor kurzem nochmal gab.
shipyourenemiesglitter.com
Wo du sagst, Leute, die du nicht magst,
eine Röhre Glitzer bestellen konntest.
Und das haben die dann ausgepackt und Glitzer
verteilt und niemand mag Glitzer
auf seinem Tisch. Das kriegst du halt nicht mehr weg.
Ja, stimmt. Das kriegst du einfach nicht mehr.
Das ist so ein ganz kleingefrieseltes
Kunststoff
Glitzerfolge.
Das ist statisch.
Das kriegst du wirklich nirgendwo mehr runter.
Da musst du wahrscheinlich mit so einer Fusselrolle drüber kommen.
Noch schlimmer war eine Alternativseite.
Die hat das Ganze verpackt in einer Röhre, die dann
springloaded war. Das heißt, jemand wurde sie aufgemacht.
Das kam der Glitzer sogar rausgeschossen.
Das war einfach nur richtig assi.
Aber hier ist was zum Beispiel,
da habe ich neulich erst drüber nachgedacht,
dass ich das gerne hätte. Das könnte man fast bestellen.
You suck at parking.
Business cards.
Das Leute unter die Scheibenwäsche klemmst.
Ja, ich hätte, also Business card ist ja,
wenn du so eine Karte irgendwo hinklemmst, ist ja noch nett.
Ich hätte das ja gerne als Sticker gehabt,
dass ich den Leuten das direkt auf die
Windschutzscheibe kleben kann oder so.
Es gibt ja so Twitter-Accounts von so
radikalen Fahrradfahrern, denen ich sehr gerne folge.
Zum Beispiel
fall mir den Namen nicht ein,
Dresden unterwegs oder sowas.
Die haben dann auch gerne Fotos von
zugeklebten, ach Quatsch, zugeparkten
Radwegen oder sowas. Immer wieder
irgendwelche UPS-Trucks oder
irgendwelche DHL-Trucks oder
Krankenwagen aus Polizei
selber, die dann mal schön massiv
einen Radweg zu fahren.
Okay, aber Krankenwagen gerne.
Krankenwagen gerne meinetwegen, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Polizei ist mir theoretisch auch
wurscht. Ich meine, es ist ja an sich...
Polizei kann das Blaulicht anmachen und mitten
auf der Spur stehen bleiben.
Vielleicht wollen sie die Straße aber trotzdem durchgängig lassen.
Ich habe noch zwei Monate bei DHL
als Zulieferer gearbeitet.
Als Nebenjob,
da dachte ich, ich brauche ein bisschen Geld.
Ich brauche auch ein bisschen Geld.
DHL zahlt tatsächlich nicht ganz bescheuert
und hat auch menschliche Arbeitsbedingungen,
zumindest da, wo ich gearbeitet habe.
Aber wo soll ich mich denn hinstellen als DHL-Fahrer?
Die Straße ist halt nur so breit,
ich kann den Geri komplett zupacken, so blank,
der halt zugänglich ist.
wenn da jetzt keine Autos davor stehen,
ansonsten bin ich halt ein bisschen angeschwürt
und ich muss halt gefühlt überall parken.
Der Job besteht ja quasi daraus,
den ganzen Tag in der Stadt einen Parkplatz zu sein.
Eben, das ist mega kacke.
Du kannst natürlich irgendwo am nächsten Parkplatz suchen
und dann die ganze Straße lang latschen
mit einem Sackkachel und den Paketen.
Aber du hast halt auch nur so viele Möglichkeiten.
Ich bin da als Radfahrer gerne lieber ein bisschen freizügiger
und rechne das den Leuten nicht an,
solange es nicht irgendjemand daherkommt
und sich wirklich einfach zu Hause auf den Parkplatz zu nehmen
auf den Radstreifen stellt.
Das finde ich natürlich ekelhaft,
aber ansonsten kann ich genauso gut als Radfahrer auch ausweichen.
Wenn du hier drüben zum Beispiel
die Nüttnitzer Straße von dieser großen
Ecke Bergstraße herkommst,
wo du an den ganzen
Instituten vorbeifährst hier,
der Radweg
ist vier Meter breit.
Die Hälfte davon ist rot.
Das ist aber kein Radweg.
Das ist ein Parkplätze.
Das sollen Parkplätze sein.
Warum ist das dann rot?
Um die Parkplätze zu designieren,
sobald ich weiß.
As far as I know,
sollen das da Parkplätze sein,
aber...
Sicher?
Das wäre ein ekelhafter Radweg.
Der ist doch absolut uneben.
Ich denke mir zumindest,
naja, dafür,
dass das irgendwie so ein Stück
oder G-Weg ist,
das ist die ganze Zeit zugeparkt.
Vielleicht hat es ja auch
vor eingebürgert,
dass das irgendwie Parkplätze sind.
Vielleicht hast du recht.
Aber als Radfahrer
fahre ich da eben auf der Straße.
Ich habe noch nie Probleme gehabt,
auf der Straße Fahrrad zu fahren.
Natürlich gibt es Leute,
die anderen Probleme
und ich...
ist das mega scheiße, wenn man da ständig Probleme hat.
Gerade wenn man im Alltag irgendwo langfährt,
wo die Strecke echt richtig beschissen ist.
Da habe ich auch starkes Mitgefühl als
leidenschaftlicher Radfahrer und nicht
Autobesitzer. Machst du das so,
dass du dich auch daran hältst, wenn du
zum Beispiel an der Kreuzung links
abbiegst, dass du dann wirklich
den dir vorgeschriebenen Weg
nimmst, nämlich über zwei Ampeln?
Nein, also im Zweifelsfall fahre ich
wie ein Auto und stelle mich einfach auf die
Liesbücher-Spur mitten auf der Kreuzung und
bieb dann halt genauso mit ab. Das mache ich nämlich auch.
Er wird mir wahrscheinlich so ein Polizist mal
ans Bein pissen
wegen irgendwann.
Aber ich sehe es auch nicht ein, dass ich hier
diese Ochsentour über mich hier gehen lasse.
Als Fahrradfahrer, normaler
Verkehrsteilnehmer,
da für links abbiegen,
zwei Ampeln mitzunehmen, dass du nämlich
einmal quer drüber und dann nochmal quer drüber musst,
das ist ziemlich assi.
Es ist auch so ein bisschen
zweischneidig,
was ich gerade sage. Auf der anderen Seite nimmt man sich
als Radfahrer auch gerne heraus, sich zu verhalten
wie ein Fußgänger und dann durch
irgendwelche Fußgänger zu wohnen.
Egal wie man unterwegs ist, man nimmt sich immer ein bisschen
mehr an Rechten raus, als das, was man eigentlich laut
STVO haben sollte. Vielleicht nicht als Autofahrer,
es sei denn, du bist meine Mom, die ich jetzt hier einfach mal
verpetze, die mal an einer Stelle,
also wer die Ecke kennt,
da wo die Wohnheime, Städtenwohnheime,
Zellischer Weg in Dresden sind, wenn man da
hochfährt zu den Wohnheimen, dann ist man
plötzlich in der Sackkasse, es sei denn, man biegt da
rechts ab in eine Straße, die eigentlich keine ist und plötzlich
steht man, stand sie mit dem Auto an der Fußgänger
und hat die Scheibe runtergelassen, gedrückt,
bis die Fußgangeampel grün wurde.
Ist das da eine Wunschstraße?
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich auch schon mal gemacht.
Das ist halt überhaupt nicht okay.
Da standst du halt plötzlich und denkst dir,
oh fuck, wie komme ich überhaupt wieder auf?
Na gut, dann fahre ich da jetzt durch.
Nächstes Mal weiß ich es besser.
Klar, sie hatte keine Ahnung.
Ich stelle die Ahnung nicht mehr in Dresden
und in der Ecke schon überhaupt nicht.
Aber da kannst du nur so viel rausnehmen.
Als Autofahrer hältst du dich normalerweise an die STVO.
Als Radfahrer bist du ein bisschen mehr in den Arschloch
und fährst dich, wie du möchtest.
als Radfahrer, als Autofahrer oder als Fußgänger.
Ja, aber als Radfahrer kannst du auch
schwerer jemanden umbringen mit deinem
Fahrzeug als Autofahrer.
Ja.
Ich finde es absolut...
Als Radfahrer
bist du irgendwie in einem anderen Modus als
Autofahrer.
Als Autofahrer stellst du
die rote Ampel nicht in Frage. Da siehst du,
da ist eine rote Ampel, du hältst automatisch
an, weil du es so beigebracht bekommen hast.
Du hast einen ganz anderen Entscheidungsablauf
als Radfahrer.
fährst auf eine rote Ampel zu als Radfahrer
und denkst dir wirklich,
muss ich hier überhaupt halten?
Muss ich jetzt hier halten? Schau ich mal kurz.
Ich fahre an einer roten Ampel vorbei,
wo ich weiß, dass eine Freundin von mir da mal
von der Polizei mit dem Fahrrad rausgezogen wurde,
weil sie bei Rot drüber gefahren ist und 40 Euro
Bußgeld gezahlt hat. Ich denke mir jedes Mal trotzdem...
Das ist auch korrekt, klar. Du solltest dir natürlich
nicht überfahren. Aber es ist
absolut super, es ist absolut in Ordnung,
dass sich Autofahrer da an sowas komplett
halten. Das ist bei Fahrradfahrern eher ein bisschen...
Du kannst aber auch mit dem Fahrrad böse Unfälle mit Fußgängern haben.
Also du solltest natürlich jetzt nicht komplett reckless sein.
Und Leute behindern das immer scheiße, egal wie du das machst.
Ich rufe nicht gerade auf, wie zu Straftaten laufen.
Nee, das ist auf keinen Fall.
Aber das ist zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt mit dem Fahrrad eine rote Ampel überfährst,
wo keine Sau ist.
Also mit dem Auto würde ich mich das trotzdem nicht trauen.
Da bin ich deutsch genug, auch als Fußgänger meistens an der roten Ampel stehen zu werden.
Aber als Radfahrer hat man irgendwie nicht ganz so die Hemmung.
Als Fußgänger hast du da mehr Hemmungen als als Radfahrer?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist mein deutsches Blut.
Lukas,
Freund von uns, der vor kurzem
in Norwegen war,
hatte da eine Story erzählt.
Er hat es, glaube ich, nicht selber erlebt oder zumindest von seinem Chef erzählt bekommen,
aber es kann so eine Friend-of-a-Friend-Story sein.
Aber es ist auch eine witzige Story, ob die jetzt real ist oder nicht.
Die Idee war, dass er
nachts an der Kreuzung stand, keine Sau da,
als Fußgänger, und die Ampel ist rot.
Und er wartet da halt. Und es kommt kein Auto,
kein Fußgänger, und plötzlich kommt halt noch so ein Typ neben ihm.
und stehen ja beide an der roten Ampel und warten
und plötzlich dreht sich der andere,
es ist in Norwegen, dreht sich der andere zu ihm um.
Na, auch Deutscher?
Das finde ich einfach wunderschön.
Das ist halt so eine Sache.
Ich war, als ich im letzten März mit meiner
Mama und Schwester in New York unterwegs war,
standen, du gehst als Fußgänger durch die Stadt,
viele, viele rote und grüne Ampeln
und typisch Großstadt, jeder geht halt so oder so
und du wusstest halt genau, wer die Deutschen sind,
weil die Deutschen wirklich immer die, die da standen
beziehungsweise die Deutschen waren die,
Familien, die dann dastanden und gemeinsam
runtergezählt haben, weil die Timer ja auch da steht,
bis sie endlich gehen konnten und jeder andere ist einfach
total gegangen. Also es ist wirklich so eine richtig
deutsche Angewohnheit, als Fußgänger sich an der Fußgängerhandel
zu halten. Also in den USA
heißt das Jaywalking und das
ist eine absolute Verkehrssünde.
Aber da bist du natürlich als Fußgänger
überall. Es ist nicht mehr eine
Verkehrssünde als hier, wenn nicht sogar wenige.
Findest du ja.
Wenn man einen besseren Begriff dafür hat,
Jaywalking bezeichne ich zwar eher so als
das, was hier zu dem Lande genauso blöd ist,
nämlich quer über die Kreuzung laufen als Fußgänger.
Anstatt sich an die Fußgängerampeln zu halten
und quasi zwei mitzunehmen,
wenn du einmal diagonal rüberlatscht.
Da wurde ich auch als Schüler schon oft von der Polizei ermahnt,
dass das natürlich überhaupt nicht geht.
Ja, gut.
Ein alter Mitbewohner von mir,
ich habe ja mal an der St. Petersburger Straße in dem Wohnheim gewohnt,
das ist gegenüber vom Kino.
Da ist auch so eine Fußgängerampel.
Und ein Mitbewohner von mir war Soziologe,
der hat dann ein Experiment gemacht mit einer Kommilitonin von ihm,
die nicht bei uns gewohnt hat.
Die saß plötzlich dann bei uns auf dem Balkon
und hat diese Ampel gefilmt.
Und der stand unten und ist immer wieder über die Kreuzung gegangen.
Aber immer dann, wenn es rot war.
Die haben gezählt, wie viele Leute
mitlaufen.
Also du hast
Leute, da ist eine rote Ampel,
die stehen da und die stehen
und warten darauf, dass es grün wird
und der kommt an
bei der roten Ampel und läuft einfach drüber.
Und dann hast du natürlich plötzlich ein Vorbild
und die Leute,
die dann plötzlich gewartet haben
laufen dann mit rüber.
Das ist sehr interessant. Also so ein Effekt, den du häufiger
hast. Warum bleibe ich nicht hier stehen,
wenn die anderen hier gerade rüberlaufen?
Nämlich ein Experiment, wo sich Leute
im Aufzug stellen, aber halt die Wand anstarren.
Und mal schauen, wie viele Leute sich ebenfalls
so ausrichten im Aufzug und die Wand anstarren
statt die Tür. Das
wollte ich als nächstes aufziehen. Das ist ja irgendwie so
ein
ungeschriebenes Gesetz,
dass man im Aufzug nicht spricht.
Und dass alle
zur Tür gucken.
Das war auch ein YouTube-Video oder sowas.
Da haben sie einfach mal geschaut,
was passiert, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie an die linke Wand gucke.
Stellen die Leute sich dann die mit einsteigen?
Wir suchen das nochmal raus und packen die Schaunhaut mit rein.
Ja, das war zumindest sehr witzig, dieser Effekt.
Dazu übrigens auch gerade einfällt, das sind Experimente,
das habe ich seit Jahren im Kopf,
ein großartiges Buch gelesen,
verrückte Experimente heißt das.
Das sind einfach nur Dinge aufgelistet,
wirklich amüsante Dinge und spannende Dinge.
Und das eine Experiment war,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
ob das überhaupt aus dem Buch stammt oder nicht.
Da bin ich jetzt gerade falsch.
Jedenfalls haben ein paar Studenten in Boston eine Forschungsreihe gestartet.
Die wollten wissen, wie lange es dauert, wenn Leute an der Kreuzung stehen im Auto,
bis die Leute hinter einem hupen, wenn es grün wird,
und für welche Faktoren dafür eben eine Rolle spielen.
Und haben halt verschiedene Automarken, Farben, Ampeln getestet, alles Mögliche
und haben da ihre Versuchsreihe gefahren.
Aber nachdem sie eben fertig waren, haben sie noch ein bisschen mehr Spaß gehabt.
Und haben halt ein paar abstrusere Faktoren ins Spiel gebracht.
Ich habe eine leicht bekleidete Frau am Straßenrand.
Plötzlich war die Zeit um ein Vielfaches höher.
Aber das absolut Schönste war, dass hier den Typen, der vorne an der Ampel steht, der quasi der Angehubte ist, der Schuldige,
den haben sie ersetzt durch einen riesigen abgefuckten amerikanischen Pickup,
haben einen starken, sehr breiten Schrank von Typen mit Glatze reingesetzt und ein Jagdgewehr in die Rückscheibe gehangen.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, hat es irgendwie drei Ampelfasen gedauert.
auch dann hat keiner gehupt, sondern der dahinter ist
ausgestiegen, ist vorgegangen und hat
lieb gebittelt, ob er da mal losfahren kann.
Ich sehe gerade das Buch, kriegst du hier schon
ab 1,49 Euro.
Genau, von Reto U. Schneider, das Buch der
verrückten Experimente. Ist unglaublich witzig,
ist sehr viel Kram drin, kann man
wirklich mal sich durchführen, gerade wenn es
1,50 Euro auch mal zukostet, dann kann man das ja auf jeden Fall mal
kaufen. Nur noch einen zweiten Teil,
den glaube ich, habe ich nie gelesen, aber vielleicht
ist der ja ähnlich amüsant.
Genau.
Den packe ich einfach mal in meinen
Einkaufswagen. Aber ich muss sagen,
ich habe in letzter Zeit ein bisschen,
ich muss mal mit meiner Bestellung ein bisschen
zurückfahren. Du meinst gerade, wo man einen Job hat,
dann fährt man das Automat
ein bisschen hoch. Ja, du hast eine ganz
andere Überlegung. Denkst du so,
das hier,
ich habe mir jetzt
einen Bildschirm
oder Laptop-Ständer
geholt. Ne, ich würde es dann glaube ich als Bildschirm-Ständer
benutzen. Von
einer Firma, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die heißen,
von denen habe ich mir schon einen Handyhalter geholt.
Der ist einfach so ein Stück gebogenes
Holz. Das ist total schick. Dann stellst du dein
Handy rein und die gleichen, die haben so ein gebogenes
Brett. Wie du kennst Podest.
So ein Podest, wo du dann deinen Laptop oder deinen Bildschirm
vorstellen kannst. Momentan habe ich das ja so, dass ich den
Zweitbildschirm irgendwie hinter dem Laptop habe und
die dann beide quasi übereinander habe.
Also Dual Monitor
halt nicht horizontal, sondern vertikal.
Aber dein Mauszeiger geht auch von der Seite
raus und nicht der Monitor.
Das virtuelle Alignment kannst du ja einstellen, wie du kannst.
Ja, aber hast du es auch übereinander da?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Krass, okay.
Also das geht, keine Frage, aber dass du damit klarkommst,
dass du mit der Maus zum oberen Rand rausgehst.
Auf Mac geht das gar nicht, wenn ich eine Menüleiste.
Auf Mac geht das auch.
Nach oben raus, aber nicht.
Doch, klar.
Dann habt ihr die Menüleiste, kommt aber in Schulitäten.
Nee, wieso?
Ich dachte, da wäre nach oben eine harte Kante.
Du hast zwei Menüleisten, das geht.
Bei Mac ist es halt ein Scheuer,
dass du da diese komische Menüleiste hast,
die meistens zu weit weg ist und dann
irgendwie... Oder hast du ja nur noch
auf dem oberen Monitor die Medioleiste? Das habe ich gerade nicht im Kopf,
aber ich glaube, die hast du auf deinem
Hauptmonitor. Ja, und was ist, wenn das der untere ist?
Das ist bei mir der untere. Das geht.
Okay, genauer umspielen.
Das geht. Zumindest
hatte ich da bislang so ein fettes
Mastering C-Make Buch unten drunter.
Als Stand.
Das muss ich
aber jetzt tatsächlich mal lesen, deswegen habe ich
das da wieder rausgenommen. Da ist jetzt mein fettes C++
Buch drunter. Das muss ich aber eigentlich auch mal lesen.
Deswegen habe ich mir dieses Brett bestellt.
Und das Schöne ist, du kannst da halt,
das ist einfach nur so ein gebogenes Brett, da kannst du halt den Laptop
oder die Tastatur oder was auch immer du extra hast,
drunter schieben. Das ist natürlich ganz angenehm.
Das heißt, du hast dein Bildschirm nicht nur ermügt, sondern hast auch
den Platz wieder zurückgebrochen, indem du da ein bisschen
was runterschieben kannst.
Du hattest dir noch was gekauft letzte Woche, so ein anderes
Brett.
Ich habe schon länger mit dem Gedanken gespielt,
mir endlich mal ein Longboard zu holen.
Dann hat mir ein Kollege
von mir, fährt jeden Tag mit seinem
Longboard auf Arbeit. Okay, spannend.
Das ist aber kein normales Longboard.
Das sieht ein bisschen abgefahrener aus.
Das ist noch ein bisschen größer und gebogener.
Und nicht so ein motorisiertes, oder?
Ja, warte mal.
Und das, was der hat, das hat nicht so...
Normalerweise haben so Longboard-Reifen,
die sind schon wesentlich größer als die von einem Skateboard.
Und Longboard-Reifen haben
so etwa die Form und Größe von einer
Cola-Dose.
Aber so fett sind die nicht, oder?
Ja, die sind aber zumindest schon eher in die Richtung.
Sodass du halt weniger Unebenheiten merkst.
Ich besaß mal ein Skateboard vor Jahren
besitzt ein Longboard, aber ich dachte, die sind
ähnlich, aber okay, vielleicht
ich habe es noch falsch bekommen. Also so ein Skateboard,
ist das jetzt blöd zu erzählen, aber so ein Skateboard
Reifen ist so, ein Longboard
ist schon so. Ja, so ist
ein bisschen schwerer Vollkass. Es geht eher
in Richtung Cola-Dose.
Aber das Brett, was der hat,
da sind die
Reifen wesentlich schmaler,
also die sind wirklich bloß so Daumen breit oder so
vielleicht zwei Zentimeter breit.
Also ich habe jetzt, muss ich sagen, ich habe auch sehr breite Daumen.
Die Hörer haben jetzt ein sehr komisches Bild von dir.
Komischer Typ, der immer so zählt mit extrem
fetten Daumen. Das ist das einzige visuelle
Merkmal, was dich ausmacht.
Ja, also ich kann mir
im Gitarrenladen, kaufe ich mir die kleinen
Pics, weil meine Verdauung dafür zu fett ist.
Na egal.
Zumindest die Reifen sind halt
eher so
hier
kutschenmäßig.
Die sind so von einer
CD-Größe. Durchmesser wie so eine Untertasse
und so
also 2 cm breit in etwa, und der hat gemeint,
der kann damit einen abgesenkten Bordstein hochfahren.
Ja, und der kommt halt echt jeden Tag damit an.
Und von dem habe ich mich mal ein bisschen beraten lassen,
und dann habe ich kurz überlegt, ob ich mir bei Amazon so ein Bord bestelle,
und dann habe ich mir gedacht, nee, alles scheiße, die sehen auch nicht schön aus,
und ich will ja irgendwie nichts mit irgendeinem komischen Muster,
mit dem ich mich nicht identifizieren kann,
und dann habe ich das erst mal gelassen.
Und dann war ich mal zufällig bei Kastad Sport drin,
Und da war eins runtergesetzt
erst von 160 auf 80
und dann von 80 auf 40 Euro.
Da habe ich gedacht, boah, das ist das.
Das kann ich einfach mal ausprobieren.
Da bin ich dann letzte Woche los und bin ich einfach mal
einen Elberadweg damit rumgefahren.
Echt super, macht Spaß.
Ich bin ja früher auch ein bisschen Skateboard gefahren.
Ich habe jetzt am rechten Fuß
eine Blase vom Antreten.
Okay, das ist ja normal, glaube ich.
Das ist, glaube ich, normal.
Eigentlich ist dir die ganze Zeit nichts passiert.
Und dann irgendwann bin ich...
bin ich dann auf dem Weg nach Hause,
doch wieder ein bisschen übermütig geworden,
da bin ich dann auf dem Fußweg gefahren und der Fußweg
ist nicht ganz so eben, da bist du halt nicht so schnell,
da habe ich halt mehr getreten und irgendwann bin ich so
100 Meter, nachdem ich schon 2 Stunden gefahren bin,
100 Meter vor meiner Wohnung,
mit dem Fuß unterm Reifen hängen geblieben,
beim Antreten und habe mich schön auf die Seite gelegt.
Also es ist nicht viel passiert,
ich habe mir irgendwie einen blauen Fleck und
ein bisschen hier auf Schürfung in der Hand.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, das wurde eigentlich verzeiht.
Ja, man muss ja irgendwann mal bluten,
sonst hat man es ja nicht richtig gemacht.
Nee, nee, nee.
War super schön. Also ich meine, ich mache ja schon seit Jahren
nicht mehr wirklich Sport.
Und wenn du dann mal wieder Skateboardest oder Longboardest
und ein bisschen rumfährst und dich tatsächlich mal auf die Fresse legst,
denkst du so, ach,
lebst noch.
Das war eigentlich so.
Also ich glaube, auch heute ist das dann mal wieder schön.
Da werde ich nachher noch mal ein bisschen raus in die Elbe
und da ein bisschen rumfahren.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich hatte ja einen Respekt, so Longboarden kommt ja eher
von so einer Abfahrtszene.
das fährt sich auch ein bisschen Snowboard-mäßig.
Eigentlich fahren viele Leute auch so abhängige Landstraßen mit runter.
Dann siehst du richtig, wie sie bremsen,
indem sie das Board irgendwie querstellen.
Dann fahren sie es fast so ein bisschen.
Krass.
Da gibt es auch krasse GoPro-Videos.
Da werde ich aber wahrscheinlich nie hinkommen.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich immer bloß ein bisschen cruisen.
Der Kollege hier von mir, der Mario,
der sonst relativ viel boardet,
und der ist, glaube ich, zweimal die Woche Wakeboarden
in dieser Wakeboard-Anlage hier in Dresden.
Uh, da habe ich mal gegrillt an dem See.
Ich dachte, da warst du schon mal Wakeboarden.
Wakeboarden weiter. Ich habe noch nie
surfen, noch nie Wakeboarden, weil ich weiß, wo man Dinge machen.
Das können wir eigentlich diesen Sommer mal machen.
Da müssen wir auch vorher gucken,
es gibt Tage, wo sie das Ding
auf halber Geschwindigkeit betreiben.
Wir hatten das mal einem Kumpel geschenkt, der
sonst auch sehr sportlich ist und da haben wir
dem einfach so einen Tag Wakeboarden spendiert
und dann haben wir ja noch selber mitgemacht.
Die haben uns aber am Anfang, als wir
die Anzüge und die Bretter
ausgeliehen haben,
gefragt, habt ihr das schon mal
gemacht? Und drei von uns so,
nö. Naja, heute ist eigentlich
ein Tag, wo wir auf voller Geschwindigkeit fahren, also
ich müsste mal gucken.
Ich habe das irgendwie
zehnmal versucht, mein weitestes war irgendwie 30 Meter,
dann bin ich immer wieder runtergeflogen und ich konnte
irgendwie die nächste Woche meine
Arme nicht anwinkeln, weil ich irgendwie
um diesen Bus gezerrt werde,
ein bisschen verletzt wurde. Hat aber auch sehr viel
Spaß gemacht, die paar Meter durchgefahren bin. Hat auch
der Ageiz, aber ich habe es nicht richtig
gekriegt. Das klingt auf jeden Fall cool.
Was wollen wir sonst noch so reden?
Ja stimmt, wir können langsam mal die Sendung anfangen.
Wir sind ja erst 47 Minuten rein hier.
Wir haben über
MobileCamp auf jeden Fall schon
gesprochen, ein paar coole Talks, die hier stattfanden.
Kann man auf jeden Fall auf mobilecamp.de, auch glaube ich
nochmal, nee, auf lineupper.com
kann man den Sessionplaner nochmal reinschauen.
Ein paar Aufzeichnen gibt es leider keine.
Schade, dass das nicht aufgezeichnet wird.
Lineupper ist doch sowas. Diese Seite
machst du auch Line-Upper,
die versuchen eigentlich gerade für solche Sachen
hier die Infrastruktur online zur Verfügung zu stellen,
an und für sich ganz cool.
Aber die Webseite ist halt
als Mobile-App gedacht.
Und wenn du mit einem normalen Desktop-Browser dahin gehst,
wenn du mit einem normalen Desktop-Browser dahin gehst,
dann kriegst du halt
so ein virtuelles Handy gezeigt.
Und da drin ist, glaube ich, die gleiche Seite, die du auf deiner App hast.
Was ja nicht so das Problem wäre,
wenn man da wenigstens scrollen könnte.
Du kannst nicht scrollen,
du musst drag and dropen auf dieser Seite.
Also nicht drag and dropen, sondern nicht droppen,
sondern du musst tatsächlich klicken und ziehen.
Wenn du dein User Agent
fakest und auf
ein anderes
Mobile-Betriebssystem
eben gehst, dann kannst du plötzlich scrollen.
Das heißt, die unterbinden das aktiv.
Was soll das?
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen eklig.
Das ist mega bescheuert.
Das gefällt mir einfach überhaupt nicht.
Gerade als ich die Seite aufgemacht habe, habe ich gemerkt,
dass ich es noch
das von 2016 in meiner History hatte.
Nein, Apoa.com
slash mobilecamp
minus 2017.
Ja, und das letzte war einfach
slash mobilecamp slash 2016.
Also im Prinzip ist die Idee ja cool,
so einen Plan zu haben für Kram,
aber ich finde das ekelhaft,
dass ich halt aktiv den Desktop-Client unterbinde.
Du kannst scrollen.
Ich kann scrollen, aber ich scrolle halt mit der gesamten Seite rundherum auch noch gleichzeitig.
ein bisschen bekloppt. Okay, ich kann auf dem Mac nicht
scrollen tatsächlich. Also Safari kriegt das nicht gepackt.
Sie machen mir da aktiv was kaputt.
Okay, du zoomst jetzt ein bisschen raus, damit du
außen nicht scrollen kannst und dann
geht das Scrollen da drin. Aber es ist auch ein bisschen,
du fühlst dich ein bisschen hackieren. Irgendwas stimmt da nicht ganz.
Ja, es ist einfach, die könnten einfach
hier, es ist ja schön, dass die Seite so
anfängt. Du siehst ein, sagen wir es mal,
es ist ein iPhone 5, was du hier siehst, oder
4. Daneben ist ein QR-Code, wo du das dann
abscannen kannst. Aber was einfach hier
reichen würde, wäre ein Link zu der nicht
nicht
vor mobilisierten Seite.
Ich habe mein User Agent, wie gesagt,
auf mein iPad gesetzt oder iPhone
und schaue mir im Vorbild jetzt
natürlich ein Mobile UI.
Da kam direkt meine nächste Beschwerde. Also meine
automatische Reaktion war hier
STRG-Shift-M
drücken in Firefox, dass ich irgendwie diese
Ansicht bekomme.
Die responsive Design Ansicht.
Die responsive Design Ansicht bekomme. Da hast du
nämlich oben so
Custom User Agent Eingabe
aufhält. Und ganz ehrlich, warum muss ich
mir den jetzt selber ausdenken?
Safari hat einen Dropdown dafür.
Du kannst natürlich eintragen, was du möchtest.
Mein nächster Schritt war dann erstmal
Firefox Android
User Agent String
bei DuckDuckCode zu suchen, um überhaupt
hier was reinpasten zu können, was den Sinn ergibt.
Was sind die Sachen, die man da überhaupt braucht?
Du willst einen Mobile Client vortauschen können,
du möchtest vielleicht mal
einen Safari vortauschen können, aber was ich
tatsächlich öfter im Internet mal nutze, ist
ich möchte vortauschen können, dass ich der Google Bot bin.
damit ein Forum mich ohne Login
jeglichen Content lesen lässt.
Oh, das geht?
Der Googlebot darf das nämlich als indizieren, weil die wollen ja in die Google-Resultate rein.
Aber Menschen natürlich nicht, die sollen sich ja anmelden.
Deswegen, jetzt sagst du einfach, du bist der Googlebot
und plötzlich darfst du alles sehen.
Gut zu wissen.
Das ist ein sehr nettes Feature, das ist ein Workaround.
Gerade wenn man viel auf älteren Foren-Softwaren unterwegs ist.
Also wenn du einen sinnvollen User-Agent-String emulieren möchtest,
dann musst du da reinschreiben Mozilla 5.
iPad, Apple Webkit,
KHTML, Like, Gaggo.
Wir hatten das User-Agent-Thema erst in der letzten Folge.
Das ist eine schöne Sache.
Ja, noch was aus der letzten Folge.
Ich hatte ja irgendwie was über Dino erzählt.
Diesen neuen kleinen
Jabber-Client.
Ich habe es tatsächlich nochmal geschafft,
den zu installieren.
Ist ganz hübsch, zerquotet nicht mehr sofort.
Cool.
Und sieht sehr nach Conversations aus.
Das ist doch schön.
ähm, ja
ein hübscher Jabba Client für einen Desktop
der alles Wichtige kann, das fehlt halt
wirklich, und ich sehe nicht
ein, dass Gargim da eine Antwort ist
ja, Gargim ist halt
ist okay, aber es ist
auch nicht wirklich stabil, also bei dem sehe ich auch nicht
dass der wirklich 100% stabil ist, aber
bei Dino, kommt der vielleicht noch
ist der noch, wie gesagt, ganz neu
aber
so viele Anwendungen für
Desktop werden einfach auch nicht mehr gebaut
habe ich den Eindruck
Ja, deine Zielaudience ist mittlerweile so breit gestreut. Also vor 20 Jahren hast du für Windows entwickelt, dann hast du für Mac entwickelt und für Linux. Heute entwickelst du für Web, für Linux, für Mac, für iOS, für Android.
dass für, letztens ist es halt noch viel mehr
dazugekommen, du erreichst halt viel
mehr Leute, wenn du eine App für
Mobile baust oder eine Web-App,
als wenn du einen Desktop-Client
für Linux baust.
Stimmt, klar.
Man merkt auch immer, wo die Prioritäten
der Hersteller liegen, beziehungsweise
der Software-Schmieden, was für Plattformen
zuerst supported werden.
Oftmals natürlich mobil
erstmal, damit
die größte Notkundenbasis da eben was hat.
Oftmals fängt es sogar mit iOS an, einfach nur, wenn man
da mehr Geld mit verdienen kann.
Und gerade wenn es dann irgendwann in die
Desktops geht, dann ist man halt natürlich
naheliegend.
Ich bin immer froh,
wenn ich auch schöne Kommandozeilen-Apps finde.
Das ist immer was wert. Ja,
freut man sich.
Kumpels von uns haben jetzt eine kleine To-Do-App
geschrieben. Irgendwie fängt man ja immer damit an,
To-Do-Apps zu bauen als erstes.
Der ist
TDO.
Spielt sich auch ganz schön.
Den habe ich erst mal benutzt, um
To-Dos für To-Do, für TDO
aufzuschreiben und dann ist mir direkt
das Feature gefehlt, To-Dos in GitHub-Igis
zu dumpen. Ich hatte das eine Zeit lang
mal probiert, meine To-Do-Liste-Komment über GitHub-Igis
zu machen. Hat das funktioniert? Nicht wirklich.
Du kommst halt gerade mobil
nicht so angenehm ran, um Dinge abzuhaken.
Es geht, aber du musst mit ein paar
Usability-Schwächen halt eben
mit denen klarkommen. Es ist halt
nicht dafür gebaut, so genutzt zu werden.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist halt eben schade.
Genau, aber wenn wir schon bei
schönen CLIs sind,
sie können auch unsere gängige Kategorie
GitHub-Stars der Woche nicht fallen lassen.
Was hast du dir so ausgesucht?
Oh, ich habe
was Schönes gefunden. Das ist nicht
wirklich benutzbar, aber ich fände es cool, wenn man
das irgendwo in Kommandozeilen
in Editoren, so in Wim oder so einbauen
könnte.
Und zwar heißt das,
habe ich das verlinkt?
Ja, Text Minimap
Und zwar hat irgendjemand
eine kleine Anwendung gebaut,
die Preilsymbole benutzt, um auf der
Kommandoteile so eine Minimap zu simulieren,
wie so viele Editoren drin sind. Ich muss sagen,
diese Minimap auf der Scrollleiste, wer hat
damit angefangen? Sublime.
Mittlerweile ist es in sehr vielen Editoren
drin. Das ist ein sehr angenehmes Feature.
Das ist super schön.
Ich habe auch extra in Naubino, als ich das
gebaut habe, oben in die
Main-Datei mit Figlet,
ein großes Fettig-Klitter,
Nobino reingeschrieben. Damit du es in der Minimap sehen kannst.
Damit es in der Minimap lesbar ist.
Das klappt aber auch nur den Editoren,
die das halt so machen, so direkt
kleiner rendern, oder?
Weil zum Beispiel Visual Studio Code
zieht da tatsächlich einfach einen Farbbalken hin,
soweit ich weiß. Sicher?
Ich hatte den Eindruck, ich konnte das noch relativ gut lesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der dann halt mit
viel Leerzeichen an der Stelle dann eben weitermacht.
Aber das spielt ja keine Rolle. Viele Editoren haben das
übernommen. Ich finde das ein cooles Feature. Ich finde es auch
interessant, dass der Mensch so gut klarkommt, damit Code
von weit weg quasi übersichtlich
Da gibt es auch unterschiedliche Philosophien.
Ich finde es gut,
das überfliegen zu können, aber gerade
wenn du so eine 5000 Zeilen
Code-Datei hast, dann ist es halt schwer.
Ja klar.
Was auch noch an vielen Stellen unterschiedlich ist,
ist, ob die
Minimap auch gefaltet wird, wenn du dein Code
faltest. Ich falte niemals.
Nichts ich aber überhaupt gar nicht.
Code-Falten mache ich
sehr exzessiv, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, da vergesse ich,
Dinge da sind und Refactor die nie wieder,
weil ich die nie mehr anschaue.
Ich komme mir einfach nicht klar,
Code zu falten. Klar, der Menü
müsste quasi dann auch klarkommen.
Ja, aber soll die gefaltet werden oder soll die
nicht gefaltet werden? Ja klar, sonst spiegelt es ja nicht
das wieder, was du gerade vor dir siehst, oder?
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber gerade wenn man
große strukturelle Unterschiede in Blöcken
hat, wenn man gerade eine fette Konfigurteil
oder was, wo ein riesiger Block Syncs drinsteht,
dann sieht man da unten, ah, da fällt irgendwas aus dem
Muster raus. Das ist einfach spannend,
solche Dinge zu finden. Das ist echt eine
coole Sache, mit der bin ich mir.
Cooler auch ein Hack für Braille-Zeichen,
um die Dime dafür
zu verwenden. Warum nicht?
Das andere mit Braille-Zeichen hattest du gefunden?
Genau, das Ding heißt Mab-Ski,
Mab-Ski, also Mab und
Aski in einem Wort irgendwie
vereint. Ich dachte erst, das hätte irgendwas mit uns
zu tun hier.
So berühmt sind wir leider nicht. Ist ein witziges
Tool, läuft leider ein bisschen
mies performant, aber macht mal, wenn
ich es mal austeste, macht es mal in einem kleinen Terminal der Müllette
Fenster auf. Das Ganze ist eine
Weltkarte, die man navigieren kann
mit Pfeiltasten zum Verschieben und
A und Z zum Reinsummen und Raussummen.
Also quasi identisch zu der Oberfläche
von OpenStreetMap eigentlich. Genau.
Bloß, dass es halt im Terminal gerendert ist
mit Braille-Zeiten. Das ist
ziemlich krass. Also du kannst dadurch,
das ist ein ziemlich krasser Hack, du hast plötzlich
anstatt einem Zeichen hast du
hast du
zweimal drei Pixel,
die du frei auswählen kannst und
dadurch, dass es
Preilzeichen? Gibt es eigentlich
genauso viele Preilzeichen, wie es
mögliche Kombinationen gibt?
Soweit ich weiß, ja.
Gut, okay, es sind voll einfach alle
als Zeichen da abzubilden.
Das ist schon ziemlich cool.
Aber das Ding hat auch
das live gerendert.
Wenn du da hoch und runter gescrollt hast,
hast du versucht nachzuvollziehen, ich habe mal
versucht nachzuvollziehen, ob die Zeilen sich verändern.
Also ob die Zeichen
einfach eine Zeile hochrutschen.
das war
nicht
diskret. Das heißt, wenn ich mir
so eine bestimmte Struktur, die du irgendwo als Breitzeichen wiedererkannt hast,
und wenn du es einfach hoch und runter scrollt hast, dann hat die sich
wirklich verändert und wurde das ein anderes Breitzeichen.
Das war schon,
das war ein CoffeeScript. Ja, das hat wahrscheinlich nicht
mir der Performance-Greit geholfen. Aber liegt das,
ist das dann noch dementsprechend alt?
Weil CoffeeScript ist doch gar nicht mehr so aktuell, oder?
Mapsky, Mapsky
ist teilweise ein paar Monate
alt, teilweise wenige Tage
bis Stunden aktuell.
Das hat irgendwie einen Typ, mit dem ich Folge
sehr aktuell entdeckt.
Es schien im September 2016, wo das gestartet hat.
Bis November 2016 ein bisschen weiterentwickelt
und dann quasi erst wieder von ein paar Tagen.
Also so Kommandozellenanwendungen
in JavaScript bauen ist auch eigentlich
gar nicht mehr so doof.
Also Möglichkeiten hat man da wunderviele.
Das ist wieder mal eine typische Kategorie.
JavaScript-Menschen haben meiner Meinung nach viel zu viel Spaß.
Da gibt es unglaublich geilen Scheiß.
Ich habe mal ein Node-Modul gesehen, mit dem konntest du
einen richtig sauberen Date-Picker
als in eine CLI eben mit reinschieben.
Das fand ich richtig, richtig
nice. Wie sehe ich schon, du googles gerade
nach AdWords Law. Ja, das hatte
der Ben vorhin erwähnt.
Das ist, glaube ich, everything that
can be written in JavaScript will
eventually be written in JavaScript.
Das ist AdWords Law, genau.
Ja, ist so.
Die Sprache, die quasi alles schluckt.
Gibt es schon Betriebssysteme
in JavaScript?
Ich würde mich einfach mal aus dem Fenster lehnen und behaupten,
dass sowas irgendwo existieren muss, aber ich meine
Irgendwo brauchst du halt eine Runtime.
Das wird sicherlich V8 sein, aber
irgendwas muss existieren,
um das zu hosten.
Also ich muss ja sagen, seitdem ich
mich wieder mehr damit beschäftige
und seitdem es
ES6 gibt und
TypeScript vor allem, ist es schon
fast wieder meine Lieblings-Skript-Sprache
geworden. Ich finde es schöner als
ich finde es mittlerweile
sogar fast schöner als Ruby.
Ich mag Ruby nur so
taktisch. Ich hasse das Tooling und das Dependency
meinet von Ruby so sehr, dass ich Ruby nie anfasse.
Ich mag Ruby nur von
der Sonntag her ausschließlich. Ansonsten
habe ich das Gefühl, mit JavaScript noch immer noch zu viele
Gotchas, in die man reinrennen kann.
Ja, zum Beispiel?
Schwierig, schwierig,
da was Spezifisches jetzt rauszusuchen.
Müsste ich besser vorbereiten,
tut mir leid, wenn ich gerade nichts explizites einleitze.
Ja, nee, natürlich ist JavaScript
sowohl schön als auch hässlich.
Das ist genauso wie C++.
Du kannst Code schreiben,
wunderbar lesbar und schön ist. Was habe ich hier neulich gelesen?
Boost
Outcome heißt es, glaube ich.
Genau. Das wäre
noch so ein GitHub-Star gewesen. Das habe ich
hier in unserer Notizenliste
drinstehen. Da hat
einer Options und Results,
wie wir sie aus Swift und Rust kennen,
in Boost für C++ nachempfunden.
Der hatte da ja
immer mal kurz auf die Sprünge. Du hast mir da einen Link
geschickt gehabt. Der hatte Options, aber
auch Outcomes. Was war denn der Unterschied?
Was war denn ein Outcome?
Also es gibt ein Feature, was
auf dem Standard-Track für C++
20 ist
und das verhält sich so ähnlich wie
Options und Results und das heißt, das ist hier
einfach in diesen Outcome-Namespace gerappt.
Das ist
ganz einfach, das ist ein ganz einfacher
Überblick für Leute, die jetzt sich plötzlich
wundern, dass wir nach einer Stunde
so lala larifari plötzlich in so einem
hardcore-technischen Thema drin sind.
Wenn er einen Wert
gibt es aus einer Funktion,
die potenziell
nicht nur
potenziell was anderes zurückgeben kann,
als du erwartest, zum Beispiel eine Suchfunktion oder sowas.
Da kann es ja passieren, dass du dein Ergebnis nicht
findest. Das wraps du dann halt in
ein Option.
Das heißt bei Swift Option,
bei Rust heißt es Option und hier heißt
es Outcome. Das heißt einfach,
mein Ergebnis kann entweder meinen
gewünschten Wert enthalten oder ganz klar
markiert,
nichts.
Zu C-Zeiten hat man das gemacht,
indem man irgendwas zurückgeben hat,
was absolut nicht im Scope ist.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Zahl zwischen 0 und 100 suche,
dann habe ich, wenn ich es nicht finde,
dann habe ich Minus 1 zurückgegeben,
um zu codieren, dass es ein schlechtes Ergebnis war.
Und dann brauche ich plötzlich die Minus 1 auch
und dann habe ich das Problem, dass ich wieder keinen Wert habe.
Oder ich suche Objekte und wenn ich das Objekt nicht finde,
dann gebe ich einen Null-Pointer zurück, was auch kacke ist.
Das fällt einem dann selbst in Java noch auf der Füße,
obwohl es ja keine richtigen Pointer gibt.
Das sind die klassischen No-Pointer-Exceptions,
die dann geworfen werden.
Genau.
Und der Unterschied zwischen einem Result und einem Option
ist, dass du bei einem Result nicht unterscheidest
zwischen etwas und nichts,
sondern zwischen OK und Fehler.
Und dann kannst du halt,
ein Option hat klassisch einen generischen Typen,
also was ich zurückgebe oder nichts.
Und ein Result hat zwei generische Typen,
dass du angeben kannst,
was für eine Art Error-Typ du zurückgibst.
Und hier gibt es irgendwie drei Sachen.
Hier gibt es irgendwie Result und Expected
und Outcome.
Ich sehe den Unterschied zwischen
Result und Outcome.
Das ist auch nicht so richtig.
Also quasi, an der Stelle muss man
eingeworfen. Es ist ganz cool, dass es jemand
quasi in Boost rein soll,
auch wenn es noch nicht da ist.
Ja, es ist wieder eine dieser klassischen Geschichten.
Wir sehen ein Feature,
was wir irgendwo haben, das möchten wir gerne
auch in C++ benutzen können.
Denken wir mal drüber nach.
Gut, als nächstes kommt,
wir kriegen es nicht mehr in den nächsten Standard rein,
weil wir haben ja gerade 2015,
das ist ja erst vor einem Jahr ein neuer Standard
rausgekommen, der nächste Standard kommt 2017
raus.
Bis dahin schaffen wir das bestimmt nicht mehr.
Also nehmen wir uns gleich für 2020
vor, das ist jetzt noch so und so
viele Jahre hin, mal schauen wir, was wir schaffen.
Dann gibt es irgendwie Features, die es in
C++14 nicht reingeschafft haben,
die es dann auch in C++17
nicht reingeschafft haben.
Jetzt überlegt man, ob die Features diese überhaupt
in C++20
Reihen schaffen.
Und dieser Moloch
an Standard entwickelt sich derartig langsam,
dass es wirklich schmerzhaft ist.
Ich habe schon Witze darüber gemacht, dass
C++26 bestimmt
super toll wird.
Das kann halt dann jedes Sprachfeature,
was man in jeder anderen Programmiersprache gesehen hat.
Nee, es wird wahrscheinlich
dann auf dem Stand sein, auf dem Rust heute ist.
Es ist einfach auch keine
dieser Anspruch, dass du mit einem modernen
Compiler noch Code von vor
15 Jahren
kompilieren können musst, ist halt
bescheuert. Ich habe mich letztens nochmal
in Closure reingefühlt und da finde ich es
mega cool, dass du in deiner
Manifestdatei,
die du mit
Liningen installierst, das ist dieser coole
Package Manager für Closure,
kannst du angeben, was für eine
Closure-Version du haben möchtest, weil
die gesamte Sprache an sich
ist eine Library, die du reinziehst
Und dann kann halt jede Library spezifizieren,
gegen welche Version sie gebaut werden möchte.
Du kannst jetzt bei Closure dementsprechend die Syntax nicht erweitern.
Das macht es natürlich schwierig.
Das kannst du nicht.
Du kannst die Features erweitern, klar, aber du kannst die Syntax
nicht umpasst.
Bei C++ kannst du auch angeben,
das ist jetzt hier Standard 11 und Standard 14
und Standard
1x oder 1y,
um dann anzugeben, das ist etwas,
was noch nicht standardisiert ist.
Aber du kannst zum Beispiel nicht mit
unterschiedlichen Libraries unterschiedliche Standards nutzen, oder?
Ich glaube nicht.
Das kannst du halt in Closure halten.
Aber was hast du auch in einem Lisp-Derivat für eine Syntax?
Du hast ja bloß Klammer auf und Klammer zu.
Das ist ja alles, was es gibt.
Das finde ich unglaublich
angenehm und kompakt in Closure.
Deswegen finde ich es eigentlich schön,
wenn sich zum Beispiel Rust dafür entscheidet,
dass es bestimmte Sachen einfach nicht in die
Sprache, sondern in die Standardbibliothek aufnimmt,
weil dann kannst du es mal eben durch was ersetzen.
Zum Beispiel Box.
Mal erst ein Keyword für deren
bestimmten heap-alorizierten Pointertypen.
ist ja jetzt egal was es ist, aber zumindest haben sie sich
irgendwann dafür entschieden, das nicht
hinter eine
Syntax zu packen, nicht als Teil
der Sprache zu machen, sondern in die Standardbibliothek
zu tun und dadurch kannst du es besser
austauschen oder ersetzen oder darauf verzichten
Das finde ich gut
Andersrum macht sie jetzt JavaScript
und
hat Sachen wie Promises
und zieht die aus der Bibliothek
Du hast ja vorher, ein Promise ist ja irgendwas
was du auch ersetzen kannst, indem du es
du zum Beispiel mit Bluebird in eine Bibliothek von außen
reinziehst, dann benutzt du plötzlich andere Promises
oder vielleicht Namespace-Study
und
rappt die jetzt in ein syntaktisches
Konstrukt, nämlich Async-Await.
Und dann hast du es plötzlich in der Sprache.
Das kannst du bei sowas wie, klar,
Async-Aurones programmieren
und dieses Await-Syntax ist
was, was du in JavaScript die ganze Zeit machst
und dementsprechend ist es
naheliegend, das auch in die Sprache zu bringen.
Aber es ist schon schöner,
eine kleinere Sprache zu haben,
weil sich eine Standardbibliothek wesentlich besser dokumentieren
und anpassen lässt als die Sprache selber.
Solange es in der Standardbibliothek ist,
ist es ja auch egal, ob es in der Sprache oder in der Standardbibliothek ist.
Ich mag bloß dieses Konzept nicht von wegen Boost zum Beispiel,
diese Library, die ich mir quasi überall in jedes Projekt reinziehen muss,
damit ich den Code so schreiben kann, wie ich es möchte.
Das hingegen finde ich wieder eklig.
Boost ist halt eine Entwicklung, die daraus gründet,
dass C++ irgendwann mal für fertig erklärt wurde
und nichts mehr dran gemacht wurde und die Leute sich dann aber
trotzdem wieder dazu entschlossen haben, daran weiterzuarbeiten.
Und Boost ist ja quasi, alles was ein Boost ist,
ist eigentlich die Standardbibliothek von morgen.
Vieles, was in Boost war, ist in die Standardbibliothek gewandert
und teilweise eins zu eins so in die Standardbibliothek übernommen worden.
Das ist, was halt daherkommt, dass sich C++ einfach nicht schnell genug
weiterentwickelt hat und in den Ansprüchen der Leute nicht hinterhergekommen ist.
Das ist ein ISO-Standard.
Du hast Meetings auf der ganzen Welt, wo sich Leute hart treffen
und dann stundenlang darüber reden, über irgendwelche White Papers,
die sie geschrieben haben, um die Sprache zu erweitern.
Und dann müssen diese Entscheidungen, die gefällt werden,
aber auch noch von nationalen Körpern, also nationalen Gremien,
dann abgesegnet werden.
Und dann kriegst du irgendwelche Beschwerden oder Vetos
von irgendwelchen Gruppen aus Tschechien
oder aus anderen Ländern,
weil es ja dieser ISO-Standard angepasst werden muss
und es ist ein Riesenprozess.
Es ist kein Wunder, dass diese Sprache
bloß alle drei Jahre es mal schafft,
eine neue Iteration rauszubringen
und die dann meistens unter den Erwartungen der Leute bleibt,
die sich noch irgendwie Module oder Konzepte wünschen,
von denen es schon seit fünf Jahren Prototypen gibt
und die wahrscheinlich in drei Jahren
immer noch nicht in der Sprache sein werden.
Das ist echt krass, was da für ein Prozess dahinter hängt.
Auf jeden Fall. Und bei anderen Sprachen,
bei Rust gibt es
dieses RFC-Konzept,
da kommt jede, alle sechs Wochen
kommt eine neue Version der Sprache raus,
die muss backward compatible sein, auf jeden Fall.
Aber du kannst
neue Features auf GitHub
debattieren, da musst du dazu auch
ein RFC schreiben, dann gibt es dazu eine Diskussion,
dann musst du es implementieren, klar.
Aber dann kannst du schon innerhalb von ein paar
Monaten
in der stabilen Version
dieser Sprache mit drin sein. Ist das fest in Rust?
dass wirklich alle paar Wochen ein neues Release rauskommt?
Das Modell von denen ist
dieses Train-Modell, was auch Ember.js
zum Beispiel hat oder Firefox.
Du hast alle sechs Wochen
sagst du, okay, was jetzt
oder anders,
du bringst täglich ein neues
Nightly raus, das fällt dir einfach aus deiner CI.
Klar, das ist ja okay. Und alle sechs Wochen
sagst du, okay, das momentane Nightly
minus Unstable Flex
ist jetzt
meine Beta und meine
Beta ist jetzt meine
Stable.
Das heißt, du markierst einfach alle sechs Wochen
die jeweilige
Nightly mit den Sachen, die du
nicht mehr als Stable markierst,
sondern mit den Sachen, die du als Stable markiert hast,
als Beta. Das liegt dann nochmal sechs Wochen
rum und kriegt nochmal ein paar Fixes, wenn
irgendwas gefunden wird.
Und dann wird es aber nochmal sechs Wochen
später dann als Stable released.
Finde ich schön sauber. Das ist sehr
einfach und übersichtlich, das Modell.
Dementsprechend ist eine Beta eigentlich
komplett identisch zu einer
Stable, bloß dass sie halt sechs Wochen jünger ist.
Und das Einzige, was
dann in der Nightly noch ist, ist, dass bei Nightly
alle Unstable Features angeschaltet
sind. Das heißt, du kannst auf der Nightly dann Sachen
benutzen, die vielleicht selbst in der
übernächsten Rust-Version noch nicht drin sind.
Was aber auch in Ordnung ist,
weil da Features
ausprobiert werden können, die eventuell auch
einfach nochmal verändert werden.
Die Features, die nicht als Stable Markets sind,
können dementsprechend sich auch
Breakage verursachen. Wenn du die benutzt,
kannst du nicht darauf verlassen, dass sie
in fünf Wochen noch genauso anfühlen oder überhaupt
noch da sind.
Was hat ja immerhin auch eine super, sauber
simple Sintex dafür, um so Feature-Flags
eben anzuschalten, auszuschalten, was du eben haben
und möchtest. Du kannst ja auch eigenen Kram
definieren. Du hast ja auch diese
Plattform-Flags, die du eben benutzen kannst und
was auch immer. Das ist ganz cool.
Das finde ich sauberer bei Swift. Die fahren
irgendwie ein bisschen manueller.
Die wissen, dass sie irgendwann eine neue Version
haben wollen, haben so eine große, grobe Roadmap
und dann können Leute ähnlich zu den
RFCs halt solche Proposals
eben einreichen, über die wird dann auf der Mailing-Liste
viel debattiert und dann gibt es
halt irgendwann die Entscheidung, die Proposals kommen
irgendwann ins Review, dann werden die von den
Review-Managern eben
dann wird noch weiter debattiert und dann
gibt es eine Entscheidung entweder ja, accepted oder
rejected oder quasi
erstmal aufgeschoben, vorerst rejected
und dann gibt es einen relativ frühen
Cut-Off dafür, was für Features in die nächste Swift-Version
eben rein dürfen und dann werden erstmal
alle Proposals, die nicht
einfach nur kleinere Dinge sind,
wieder geschlossen und die müssen dann später
normal einreichen und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz
so schön und sauber. Das ist aber
angelehnt an den RFC-Prozess von Rust,
so wie ich das verstanden habe, haben sie das relativ
nah übernommen. Also bei Rust ist es auch so, dass halt so ein
RFC eine Weile diskutiert wird und dann
sind die, die
da gibt es halt auf GitHub immer
Tracking-Issues dazu, das ist
auch immer etwas Mühsam, das zu lesen.
Aber am Anfang muss immer einer
tatsächlich das Proposal schreiben, da gibt es ein
Template für und das wird dann glaube ich auch
immer mal wieder aktualisiert, dass das auch wirklich den Stand
von der Diskussion widerspiegelt.
und dann gibt es eine
Final Commenting
Period, FCP.
Das wird auch This Week in Rust
immer nochmal namentlich
erwähnt übrigens für diese RFCs.
Das ist jetzt hier bald Sense.
Wir reden jetzt noch eine Woche drüber
und danach muss eine Entscheidung
gefällt werden. Und dann heißt es
entweder Hey oder Ney.
Wie heißt es? Yay oder Ney.
Ich finde immer bekloppt, dass die wieder so ähnlich klingen.
Es bietet sich super an für
Abstimmung
großen Saal, ja, Prüfer bitte alle, yay und nay.
Yay.
Ja, dann
ist es halt eine Nachricht,
dass zum Beispiel das oder das, hier
Fragzeichen-Syntax, das ist mal eine syntaktische
Veränderung gewesen, jetzt stabilisiert
wird.
Dann hast du meistens, dann hast du dann vielleicht noch
sowas wie, ja, wir haben uns noch mehr dafür vorgestellt,
aber wir nehmen erst bloß
ein Subset davon in die stabile Sprache auf.
Aber der Prozess ist
an und für sich sehr schön nachvollziehbar
führt auch zu schnellen Veränderungen.
Wie heißt das?
Progress without Stagnation.
Stability without Stagnation.
Gefühl, klappt der Prozess in der Swift-Feld aber nicht so sehr.
In der Swift-Feld verändert sich häufiger die Syntax.
Ja, am Anfang, klar.
Jetzt ist Source Stable.
Also jetzt soll mit neuen Versionen von Swift
immer noch der alte Bauba bleiben, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist jetzt eben festgelegt worden.
Aber es gab schon öfter,
es gibt das eine große, böse Proposal.
was durchgekommen ist und die Access Control Levels
alle ein bisschen umgebaut hat.
Jetzt gibt es diese ekelhaften Dinge,
wie File Private neben Private, Public und Internal.
Und es gefällt keinem das aktuelle Konzept,
aber jetzt wollen die Leute das auch nicht mehr ändern,
nachdem man da einmal angekommen ist.
Was? File Private?
Früher hattest du in Swift Public, Internal und Private
und das war es an Access Control Modifier.
Mehr willst du eigentlich auch nicht.
Was hat denn nur Pub? Das war es ja schon.
Und ich finde es auch, ehrlich gesagt, recht angenehm,
wenn man das simpel hält.
Und dann haben sie irgendwann eingeführt,
Private jetzt nur noch den aktuellen Scope
beinhaltet. Du kannst es nur in dem Scope
drauf zugreifen.
Und File Private ist halt das, was
vorher Private war, nämlich privat
auf die Datei beschränkt. Was Leuten aber anscheinend
nicht klar war, ist, dass Private
halt auch nicht das in Zwift recht typische
Extension-Pattern zulässt,
weil du dann halt in einem anderen Scope bist.
Und plötzlich nutzt jeder File Private, was vorher eigentlich bloß
so eine Art Sache sein sollte, die man selten
nutzt. Weil jetzt ist es halt absolut
undurchsichtig geworden. Und jetzt kommen Leute
daher und haben unglaublich komplizierte
Proposals für unglaublich komplizierte
Konzepte, die du damit einbauen könntest,
um das wieder zu beheben.
Und das ist alles ein bisschen ekelhaft geworden. Ich hoffe,
das wird irgendwann noch mal ein bisschen behoben
und besser gemacht.
Aber mir gefällt die aktuelle Lösung einfach
überhaupt nicht. Mal schauen,
wo wir da hinkommen. Wer entscheidet denn bei
Swift über solche Sachen? Ja, quasi
die endgültige Entscheidung treffen die Leute, die
das Review führen, also das Core-Team.
Aber die Community
ist halt letztendlich
diejenigen, die sich befragen dafür und die sich auf der
Mailing-Liste äußern und da auch ihr Input
liefern. Aber gefühlt
alle, es beschweren
sich viel mehr Leute, als die auf der Mailing-Liste
tatsächlich mitschreiben. Ich schreibe
da selten tatsächlich mit. Ich lese öfter mal,
vor allem, es gibt so drei große
Mailing-Listen. Die Announce-Mailing-Liste
lese ich immer, die User-Mailing-Liste so gut
wie nie und die Evolution-Mailing-Liste,
das ist die, wo eben über Features gesprochen wird.
Da lese ich
hin und wieder mal mit, aber das ist halt echt viel zu viel
Content und das Gefühl ist eine Mailing-Liste auch
der falsche Ansatz,
um Kommunikation auf
der Menge abzuhandeln.
Da ist Rust schon ein bisschen
moderner. Die haben
Tracking Issues auf GitHub und die haben
einen Internal Discourse.
Ja, Swift migriert gerade auf
einen Discourse. Es gibt
einen Testdiscourse, was jetzt halt eine Weile läuft,
aber es gibt die
Absichtigung, das demnächst mal wirklich
offiziell zu machen.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die
Mailing-Liste, der gibt halt schon Sinn irgendwo,
damit anzufangen. Ich verstehe auch das
Reasoning dahinter, aber wir leben
mit dem Gefühl, also ich möchte nicht auch Leuten
nahe treten, die Mailinglisten sehr mögen.
Ich mag Mailinglisten auch sehr, gerade
weil ich halt jeder sein eigenes Tooling
dafür nutzen kann, aber
es gibt halt auch nicht so das
gute Tooling für Mailinglisten.
Und gerade wenn halt das Volumen
wie auf der Swift-Mailingliste eben damit
drüber läuft und dann bin ich halt mit jedem
Mail-Client angeschmiert. Und es gibt halt immer noch
die Leute, die dann halt daherkommen und sich die
Mailingliste in ihre Inbox pipen und halt
und später merken, das war eine blöde Idee.
Und das darfst du halt überhaupt nicht machen.
Eigentlich ist das,
wundert mich das, warum das nicht ein Standardfeature
von allen Mail-Clients ist,
dass sobald irgendwo,
wie hieß dieser Tag?
Mail-List-ID.
Also es gibt,
drin steht,
es gibt ja einen extra, ich weiß nicht, wie er genau heißt,
einen extra Header in E-Mails,
der darauf hindeutet,
das ist jetzt eine Mail aus einer Mailing-List
und die Mailing-List heißt so und so.
Das war ein geiles Feature von dem
Opera E-Mail-Client.
Opera hat ja auch einen E-Mail-Client drin gehabt.
Ich habe ihn ja nie benutzt, glaube ich.
Opera ist ja eigentlich so eine Suite gewesen, wie das alte
Muster, aber ich will jetzt nicht ausschweifen, aber das eine
schöne Feature war, dass du direkt so eine virtuelle
Ansicht Mailing-List hattest.
Wo der einfach die ganzen E-Mails
nach diesem Tag sortiert hat.
Warum
das bei anderen E-Mail-Clients gefährdet? Aber gut,
auf der anderen Seite werden auch E-Mail-Clients aktuell nicht mehr
wirklich weiterentwickelt.
Es gibt irgendwie keinen.
Was die Leute heutzutage nutzen, gefühlt nur noch Webmail-Client.
Ich heigere mich noch, aber ich weiß nicht, wie lange noch,
weil irgendwann hängst du halt auf nicht mehr Supported oder Software rum.
Ja, zum Beispiel ein Feature von Discourse ist dieser Mating-List-Modus,
dass du alles, was du kriegst, alles, was geschrieben wird, per E-Mail bekommst
und dass du auch per E-Mail auf Sachen antworten kannst.
Das ist super schön, weil Leute sagen,
ich möchte aber die Sachen aufs Handy bekommen
und ich möchte nicht Discourse in meinem Browser auf dem Handy laden müssen.
Vor allem, weil die mobile App von Diskurs
halt wirklich bloß ein Webview ist.
Aber die brauchen halt auch keine App.
Die brauchen keine App.
Die haben diesen Mailing-Modus, der klasse funktioniert.
Die haben eine super responsive mobile Seite,
die funktioniert.
Was brauchst du, willst du eine App hosten?
Aus dem ist eine App immer scheiße,
wenn deine Nutzer die App auch,
die Plattform auch selber hosten.
Weil dann grenzt du in ganz viele witzige Probleme rein.
Nicht zuletzt, dass Pugnotification
unglaublich kompliziert werden.
Du redest immer in solchen Blätten,
dass es schwer ist, da zwischendurch mal kurz was zu sagen.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich gerne eine App hätte,
ist, dass du halt wirklich Push-Notifications
bekommst. Dass du
sagen kannst, gib mir mal einen Hinweis, wenn auf diesem
Thread was passiert. Das kriege ich bei Diskurs häufig nicht mit.
Es sei denn, ich lese wirklich
exklusiv meine E-Mails auf dem Handy und das mache ich nicht.
Das möchte ich auch nicht unbedingt.
Das ist ja klar, verständlich.
Aber ja, wenn jede App
für Push-Notifications, die es haben kann,
die ganze Zeit
einen Socket offen lässt zu irgendeinem
Server, zu deinem
zu einem von deinen fünf Discourse-Boards, auf denen du bist,
zu deinem E-Mail-Programm, zu Jabba, zu Twitter, zu was weiß ich,
dann ist halt irgendwann dein Akku leer.
Deswegen haben die ganzen Handy-Entwickler angefangen,
das für dich zu wrappen und zu abstrahieren.
Deswegen gibt es für Android Google Push.
Du gehst halt quasi über die zwei Push-Provider,
über Apple und Google-Server.
Genau, also wenn du ein Handy hast, ob es ein Android ist oder ein iPhone,
dann kriegst du eigentlich alle Push-Notifications von allen Mails,
eigentlich von Apple, damit du nur zu diesem Notification-Server
eine Verbindung aufhalten musst und du Strom sparen kannst.
Twitter und sogar auch sowas wie Signal liefern halt die Nachrichten
über Apple oder über den Google-Push-Dienst aus.
Das hat Vorteile, es hat aber auch Nachteile.
Wenn man selber was basteln möchte, ist das halt nicht sonderlich.
Das klingt jetzt ja erstmal nach super ekelhaft und absolut unsicher,
aber die Sachen sind natürlich auch verschlüsselt und gerade iOS.
Ich weiß einfach nicht, wie es bei Android aussieht,
weil ich iOS-Entwickler bin.
gerade bei iOS kann ich die Push-Node-Tagent
auch so verschlüsseln, dass Apple überhaupt kein Content davon sieht,
aber meine App auf dem Endgerät
die Payload wieder entschlüsseln kann.
Es hat aber den Zeiteffekt, oder es impliziert,
dass jedes
Mobiltelefon von seinem Hersteller
kontinuierlich getrackt ist, beziehungsweise
dass jedes Mobiltelefon mit seinem Hersteller
eine kontinuierliche Netzwerkverbindung hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das technisch funktioniert.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass mein iPhone wirklich alle drei Sekunden
bei Apple-Tagent-Anfrag beziehungsweise den Socket offen hält.
Ich glaube das nicht, dass das so
stupide läuft, aber ich weiß es einfach nicht anders.
das, soweit ich weiß,
liegt unter dem Google
Push-Service einfach bloß
Java unten drunter. Echt? Okay, das ist ja
witzig, das ist ja cool.
Das ist natürlich eine relativ alte Information,
die mittlerweile schon wieder überholt sein kann, aber
im Endeffekt
ist es nichts weiter als
Presence und PubSub.
Ich mache mein Telefon an,
mein Telefon wacht auf, mein Telefon sagt
seinem Info-Provider,
seinem Push-Provider, ich bin übrigens da,
ist irgendwas passiert.
und das heißt natürlich, dass dann
dann sagt mir
Google
oder dann sagt mir Apple, ja übrigens
du hast, bei E-Mail ist es halt
zierisch edlich, aber bei einem anderen, gut okay,
du hast hier eine
Twitter-Nachricht bekommen, du hast eine Diskurs-Nachricht
bekommen, du hast, was gibt es noch, eine
Instagram-Nachricht bekommen, hier, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack
und dann kriegen die, dann gibt es
intern einen Dispatcher, der das
breitschickt und dann kriegen die
Twitter-App das nicht direkt von
Twitter.com, sondern von diesem Dispatcher
intern.
Es ist schon nicht doof,
aber es ist auch irgendwie ziemlich
die haben halt auch Metadaten. Die wissen halt, welche App
schickt mir wie oft eine Push-Notification.
Und wenn da im Kleintext gerade was drinsteht, könnt ihr natürlich
auch wissen, was da eben drinsteht.
Ich habe letztens erst in eine kleine App mal Push-Notifications
für iOS mit eingebaut.
Ist halt witzig, wie das funktioniert. Du musst halt das Zertifikat
haben von deinem Entwickler-Account.
Von deinem Entwickler-Account ein Zertifikat,
mit dem du die Notification, die du an Apple
weiterleitest, die haben da übrigens, da schickst du binär
Daten ins Socket rein, was halt
sehr performant ist, damit du halt Millionen von Push-Notifikationen
daraus schicken kannst.
Deswegen frage ich mich auch, ob diese
Aussage mit Jabba wirklich noch wahr ist,
weil es an und für sich
musste was
anderes machen, als die XML-Nachrichten
schicken. Na klar. Jedenfalls musst du
halt, wie gesagt, dieses Zertifikat haben, damit
du eine Push-Notification an ein Gerät schicken kannst.
Und jetzt beispielsweise
die Discourse-App, die nicht existiert,
die müsste halt irgendwie
damit klarkommen, dass Leute von ihren selbstgehauen
Servern Push-Notification schicken
wollen. Und wie kriegt man jetzt da
die Authentication hin, dass die App, die von
Discord selbst entwickelt ist, dieses
Entwicklerzertifikat, dieses Push-Notification-Zertifikat
da eben weiter reicht. Einfacher wäre es
natürlich, dass die Discord-Instanz dann irgendwie einen
zentralen Discord-Server wieder zentralisiert
zusammenlaufen wird. Das ist aber auch eben kacke, logisch.
Es war ja nicht nur,
das Hauptargument war ja Stromsparen.
Es ging ja nicht nur darum, dass du nur
einen Zock aufhältst, sondern
dass auch die Apps die ganze Zeit
nicht offen gehalten werden müssen.
Das heißt, normalerweise
der naive Ansatz wäre,
ich lasse Twitter die ganze Zeit laufen und Twitter
fragt die ganze Zeit
twitter.com die API ab,
um rauszukriegen, ob es eine neue
Nachricht bekommen hat. Das möchtest du aber nicht,
sondern du möchtest eine,
solange es mit Twitter ist, ist okay, aber es gibt ja halt noch fünf andere,
sagen wir, du hast fünf
vergleichbare Apps laufen. Die möchtest du
nicht die ganze Zeit laufen lassen müssen.
Du kannst sie als Android einfach
einfrieren und aus dem Speicher
nehmen, meinetwegen komplett schließen und
Dann hast du halt diesen minimalen Systemdienstlaufen,
der alle Notifications entgegennimmt.
Und wenn da eine Twitter-Notification dabei ist,
dann wächst du halt Twitter nochmal kurz wieder auf.
Einschläfern.
Ja klar, das ist halt
rechtsauber. Und so funktionieren
ja Push-Notifications auf unseren Geräten.
Wie klappen Push-Notifications eigentlich, wenn du die
Google Play-Services nicht nutzt auf Android?
Ja, nicht.
Oh, okay.
Deswegen brauchen viele Apps,
von denen du es nicht erwartest,
die Google Play-Services.
Also witzigerweise Twitter gerade nicht.
Ich hatte mal auf einem Tablet
einen Cyanage-Mod installiert, wo ich
es irgendwie nicht geschafft habe,
die Google-Play-Service zum Lauf zu bringen.
Da habe ich einfach so Twitter drauf geschmissen, dass das trotzdem
funktioniert. Ich glaube, es hat mir aber keine
Notifications geschickt.
Manchmal haben vielleicht
manche Apps dazu ein Fallback.
Aber dann musst du halt kontinuierlich im Hintergrund laufen.
Dann kriegen wir halt keine Notifications, wenn sie
gerade nicht an sind. Das ist ja eklig.
Naja, vielleicht auch
Ich habe jetzt neulich mal
eine App ausprobiert, die quasi
Twitter-Domain-spezifisch ist.
Das hieß DevRant.
Das war einfach bloß, da konntest du
Rants hin und her schicken.
Du konntest die liken und du konntest
dir so einen kleinen Avatar zusammenstellen.
Das war ein Typ, der am Schreibtisch sitzt
von einem Laptop und erst ab
5 oder 10 Likes oder
Rant-Likes konntest du
den modifizieren und den so aussehen lassen
wie du. Du konntest auch wieder das T-Shirt anpassen
und die Brille und die Haare und den Laptop,
vor dem er sitzt und sowas.
Wissiges Konzept.
Ja, ich habe einmal was gerantet
und dann kamen halt ein paar Kommentare dazu
und dann dachte ich, das ist schön, aber nee.
Ich bleibe kein Twitter.
Wir sind ein bisschen
abgeschweift von unseren GitHub-Stars, wo wir eigentlich waren.
Was hast du denn noch?
Was habe ich denn noch? Achso,
ich möchte mal lobend erwähnen, dass
meine Library in anderen Sachen genutzt wird.
Und das eine ist
Alert After.
also die Library, von der ich rede, ist so eine kleine
einfach Neuimplementierung
von LibNotify in Rust,
womit ich Desktop-Notifications abschicken
kann. Das habe ich irgendwann mal gebaut,
weil ich sowas wie CatchMyBus
in Rust bauen wollte. Da gab es schon mal
darüber geredet.
Und genau, das hat ja seit kurzem
durch die Hilfe von Felix
auch minimalen
Mac-Support und da hat jemand was gebaut,
was auf Mac und
auf Linux funktioniert mit meiner
Library, das heißt Alert After.
Das schreibst du einfach
A-A, Alert After, vor
irgendeinem Kommandozeilenaufruf und sobald
der fertig ist, kriegst du eine Notification davon.
Ach, schön. Und zwar eine Notification
mit dem Icon von der Anwendung, die fertig
geworden ist. Das findet heraus, was du aufrufst
und dann ist das ganz cool.
Das, wie gesagt, out of the box,
auf Mac und auf Linux mit meiner App
funktioniert und für Windows hat er dann nochmal
irgendwie was Eigenes gebaut. Ich habe kurz überlegt,
ob ich diesen Windows-Support
in meine Notify-App einbauen,
aber ich bin bis jetzt nicht dazu gekommen.
Also du wirst bei dem die Windows-Implementation einfach rausreißen,
rüberziehen, damit das sauer wegkappstabiert ist?
Na, ich hätte es halt schön
gefunden, wenn man mit meiner Library auf allen drei
Systemen Notifications produziert. Na klar,
das will man ja quasi eigentlich auch.
Aber ich habe es, dadurch, dass ich
keinen privaten Windows-Rechner
habe, auf dem auch noch
die ganze Visual Studio Suite läuft, mit dem ich
das entwickeln müsste, ich müsste ja auch
wie mit WinRT sprechen und da habe ich
keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Krass.
Ich kenne keinen direkt guten Windows-Rechner.
Also es gibt zwei WinRT.
Die darf man nicht verwechseln. Es gibt dieses komische
Windows RT, was dieses abgespeckte
Windows 8 war.
Und dann gibt es aber noch Windows RT. Das ist die
Runtime. Das ist quasi
nochmal so eine Entwicklungsumgebung wie
Foundation für Windows.
Naja, zumindest. Es gibt dieses
Alert After und dann gibt es noch
Slock Notify und
Slog ist eine
Log Library
für Rust, mit denen man
schöne
Namespaced-Logs produzieren kann,
wo dann immer davor steht, in welchem Modul die aufgerufen
wurden. Das ist ganz schön.
Das heißt, du initialisierst das am Anfang einmal
und dann hast du Makros, mit denen du
an bestimmten Stellen ähnlich wie Printline
sagen kannst, Info, Warn,
Trace, Debug und Error.
Und dann hat er einfach,
das ist quasi eine Quelle,
und dann kannst du unterschiedliche Senken definieren
und das möchtest du machen,
weil du entweder auf die Kommandozeile
pipen möchtest oder an irgendeinen Systemdienst
oder an irgendeinen Webdienst,
wenn du eine Anwendung schreibst,
die vielleicht
als Client irgendwo läuft,
dass du Fehlermeldungen direkt
nach Hause schicken kannst und
der hat mit dieser Desktop-Notification-Library
einfach eine Senke gebaut,
sodass Log-Warnings
und Errors auf deinem
Desktop-Client als kleiner
angezeigt. Sehr witzig. Warum nicht?
Auch ganz cool. Ein bisschen einfacher sich durchklicken.
Ja, ich hatte auch schon mal selber angefangen, so was zu machen
und habe mir dann immer gedacht, naja.
Aber ich finde es schön, dass es Leute benutzen.
Es ist immer schön, wenn du siehst, dass Leute
Code, den du schreibst, weiterverwenden für was anderes.
Auf jeden Fall. Wie schauen deine
Creator.io Download-Statistics jetzt aus?
Also das Ding ist irgendwie 4000 mal runtergeladen.
Für Notify Rust? Notify Rust, ja.
Nice, ist doch schön.
Cool. Zählt eigentlich auch jeder Travis-Bild von deinen
Dependents auch mit rein?
Das frage ich mich halt immer. Also wenn du
ich habe ja auch so ein paar Sachen,
die ich für mich selber gebaut hatte,
in Ruby
ausgelagert, in Gems
und die auf Ruby-Gems hochgeladen
und da habe ich absolut irre
Download-Zahlen gesehen, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
das kann absolut nicht stimmen.
Da bist du irgendwie schon am ersten Tag
mehrere hundertmal runtergeladen worden und da dachte ich mir,
das ist noch gar nicht fertig.
Das heißt bei mir auch bei NPM aus,
für Dinge wie DVB.js, was ich halt kaum
Nutzer vermute, was du meinst,
weil es auch stimmt, aber da sind halt
immer ein paar hundert Downloads, aber ich meine,
viel davon kann automatischer Crawler
sonstigen Kram sein, die halt Dinge
aggregieren und sonst wie, aber da muss doch auch
Travis mit reinzählen. Also DVB.js
wird, glaube ich, verwendet. Ich habe neulich
auf Arbeit
ein Gespräch mitgehört von zwei Kollegen.
Der eine hat so was, der hat gerade ein bisschen
über Machine Learning geredet und der macht viel
mit Amazon Alexa und da
schreiben wir irgendwelche Behaviors für.
Skills heißen die, glaube ich.
Und der hat ein Alexa-Skill
geschrieben und hat DVB.js.
Dafür glaube ich.
Damit er Alexa fragen kann.
Achso, genau. Und der hat sich darüber beschwert, dass die meisten Sachen nur so
laufen wie
Alexa, wann kann ich vom Hauptbahnhof
zum Albertplatz fahren?
Muss ich das Alexa jetzt eigentlich ausbieben beim Edit?
Damit ich jetzt nicht
irgendwann höre. Alexa, mach das Licht aus.
Sorry.
Dann hat es ein bisschen Spaß.
Alexa,
kauf mir ein Schwimmbecken.
Okay, das blieb ich wirklich.
Ich habe in irgendeinem Podcast mal gehört,
Alexa, kaufe jetzt 20 Tonnen Hundefutter.
Bestätigen. Kauf bestätigen.
Hörst du jedes Mal bei D-Radio Wissen,
was übrigens ab jetzt Deutschlandfunk Nova heißt.
Da machen es sich auch manchmal Spaß,
wenn sie über Alexa reden,
dass sie dann solche Sachen sagen.
Und dann hinterher anmerken,
wenn das jetzt bei euch gerade so etwas geführt hat,
dann schreibt uns doch mal bitte.
gab es nicht auch eine XCED vor kurzem
zu? War es nicht genauso
mit dem Hundefutter in dem XCED?
Zumindest hatte der sich beschwert, dass die meisten
Sachen einfach
Befehle für Alexa sind
und sagen, Alexa mach mal dies und jenes
und der wollte das gerne
ambienter haben, dass der weiß
ich fahre meistens, wenn ich abends
fahre in die Neustadt
oder wenn ich morgens fahre, fahre ich auf Arbeit
oder wenn ich mittags fahre, fahre ich
keine Ahnung, zum Arzt
und dass mir Alexa von
sich aus sagt, wann
ich losmüsste,
ohne dass ich dem irgendwelche komplexen Sachen
sagen muss. Und das hat er gebaut und da hat er deine
DVB.js-Library verwendet.
Das gefällt mir. Kurz follow-up,
ich habe es gerade mal rausgesucht, das fand ich's crazy.
Du kommst zu Besuch bei jemandem rein.
Thanks for inviting us. Alexa,
order two tons of cream corn. Alexa,
confirm purchase.
When visiting a new house, it's good to check
whether they have an always-on device transmitting your
Conversation somewhere.
Ich setze die 1807.
Ach ja.
Aber finde ich cool, dass
du benutzt wirst. Ich hätte gerne tatsächlich Alexa
nur für diesen Fall, aber ich will kein
Voice-Activated-Device daheim haben.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich habe ja überlegt, ob das was für Großeltern wäre.
Tatsächlich wäre das,
was ganz praktisch ist für Großeltern.
Ich glaube, mein Opa würde voll drauf abfahren.
Also wenn du dann sagst, Alexa, ruf meinen Enkel an.
Man stellt Großeltern immer so hin als die Tech-Nutzer,
die nichts anderes nutzen, die mit Tech nur interagieren,
um mit ihren Enkeln zu kommunizieren.
Das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Meine Großeltern sind sehr glücklich mit ihren iPads
und spielen darauf Scrabble und Surfen und Krams und alles Mögliche.
Es ist ja sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich habe eine Großmutter, die ist jetzt 93,
der haben wir zum 90. einen Kindle geschenkt.
Damit die nicht, weil sie jetzt schon ein bisschen schlechter Luft kriegt,
aber immer noch sehr aktiv ist, die ist halt regelmäßig
losgezogen in die Bibliothek und hat sich mit ihrem
kleinen Rolli irgendwie so
fünf Bücher geholt.
Fünf dicke Bücher, weil die irgendwie gefühlt
so ein dickes Buch innerhalb von anderthalb Tagen
durchlesen. Und weil das
ein bisschen aufwendig wird für sie und weil
teilweise die Schrift auch vielleicht schon ein Tick zu klein
ist, hat mein Vater ihr einen Kindel
geschenkt und der
kommt freitags eh immer zum Essen bei ihr vorbei
und da lebt er ihr neue Bücher da drauf.
Und da ist sie sehr zufrieden mit. Meint aber mittlerweile,
nachdem ich sie getroffen habe, sie hat das Ding jetzt schon drei Jahre
dass sie schon doch die alten Bücher bevorzugt.
Weil das haptische Schlimmer ist.
Das hat sie direkt so gesagt.
Dann habe ich eine andere Großtante.
Die ist nicht wirklich meine Tante,
aber die nennen wir alle Tante.
Das ist so eine Freundin der Familie.
Die ist noch ein bisschen älter.
Die ist jetzt 95 geworden.
Und die ist eine sehr aktive WhatsApp-Nutzer.
Also die schreibt wirklich wie blöde Nachrichten hin und her.
schickt dir, dann kriegst du dann von irgendwelchen
Urgroßenkeln, die sie mittlerweile hat,
kriegst du halt Fotos auf WhatsApp.
Das ist total witzig, auf jeden Fall.
Und meine Mutter, wenn ich bei der bin und wir irgendwas
machen zusammen, dann schickt die dir auch immer mal ein Foto
auf WhatsApp und kriegt sie dann schöne
Antworten drauf. Mal ganz kurz zum Kindle.
Mich stört das immer, dass Leute so meinen,
wenn ich mit dem Kindle lese, dann gibt es nur das eine
oder das andere. Das heißt, ich konvertiere entweder zum
E-Book-Leser und darf nie wieder Papierbücher
anfassen oder ich nutze
niemals ein E-Book und lese nur Papier.
Ich fühle mich recht gut in dem Zwischenraum.
Ich lese gerne mit meinem Kindle,
aber ich lese auch gerne mit meinem Buch.
Und ich finde, das ist beides möglich.
Und warum auch nicht.
Also ich hatte eine Zeit lang den Kindle
und habe den für Nachrichten benutzt.
Das finde ich schwierig.
Und das war wirklich schwierig.
Es gibt ja dieses E-Book-Verwaltungstool, Caliber.
Caliber.
Eigentlich schön.
Ich finde, das Kinderfeature davon war,
dass du, ist es immer noch,
dass du dann Nachrichtenseiten, also Newsfeeds abonnieren konntest.
Über RSS.
Und viele Sachen hat er dir schon voreingestellt.
Das heißt, du konntest dir hier eine Sammlung zusammenklicken.
Bisschen Heise, bisschen Telepolis, bisschen Spiegel,
bisschen Spektrum der Wissenschaft oder so was.
Und dann hat er dir die letzten sieben Tage runtergeladen,
zusammengestellt.
Oder er hat es, glaube ich, kontinuierlich runtergeladen.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Und hat dir das dann zusammengestellt.
und dann hast du auf dem Kindle wirklich eine schöne
Offline-Variante davon gehabt,
wo du die einzelnen,
also bei so Nachrichtenseiten
wie FATS oder wie
bei Süddeutschen hast du dann wirklich
Politik, Kultur,
Wirtschaft als einzelne Kapitel gehabt
und du hast eine sehr schöne
E-Book-Variante dieser einzelnen
Magazine gehabt, aber halt auch sonst wie Telepolis,
was du auch selten liest, weil es halt
Ja, aber das ist ein cooles
Feature auf jeden Fall. Das habe ich dann, das habe ich mir
dann schon häufiger mal
aufgeladen und bin dann mit dem Kindle in der Straßenbahn
unterwegs gewesen und habe dann
dort in Ruhe das gelesen. Ich finde das, bei dem alten
Kindle, den ich hatte, fand ich das sogar
als Feature, dass der kein Touchscreen
hat, weil du den ganz anders
halten kannst, als so ein Gerät mit Touchscreen.
Beim Touchscreen fasst du das nicht
so an. Das ist auch noch so etwas
Schönes an dem Buch. Du kannst das Buch auf der
Lesefläche anfassen, ohne dass
dein Bild sich verschiebt, du weiterblätterst
oder irgendwas. Bei so einem Touchscreen-Gerät
hast du die ganze Zeit Angst, dass du irgendwas
veränderst. Und bei diesem alten Kindle,
was war das, ein 3 oder sowas,
der sieht ja auch noch so aus
wie aus Star Trek, diese Pads,
diese grauen Pads, die die hatten.
Das fand ich eigentlich schon ziemlich geil.
Ich kann den leider nicht mehr nehmen, weil der Akku zu durch ist.
Aber das Ding
war ziemlich schön.
Als jemand, der drei Kindles bisher besessen hat
und das aktuellste mit Touchscreen,
erteile ich deine Gedanken, die Knöpfe waren angenehm.
Es ist angenehm, das Alter auch mal kurz in der Hand zu halten,
einfach einen Daumen auf dem Display zu haben.
Aber es ist nicht so sehr ein Problem,
wie ich anfangs erwartet habe.
Also auf dem Tastchenkinder ist es auch angenehm,
dass es einfach überhaupt kein Button bis auf den Einschalter hat.
Und du kannst auf dem Display auch mal einfach hin und her swipen,
ohne dass was passiert,
solange du nicht die Rechts-Links-Geste hast
oder auf einem Wort explizit kurz drauf hältst,
um es zu highlighten.
Also wenn da Dreck zum Beispiel drauf ist,
kann ich auch einfach auf dem Dreck den Langton weg swipen,
ohne dass das als Geste erkannt wird und irgendwas tut.
Es war ja, glaube ich, sogar ein Feature,
was in einer Keynote bei Apple mal verkauft wurde,
als Feature vom iPad,
dass das irgendwie so Thumb-Recognition hat.
dass es erkennt, an welcher Stelle ein Touch wahrscheinlich
ein Daumen ist und dementsprechend nicht drauf reagiert werden muss.
Weil es wirklich,
also an der Stelle ging mir Touch-Train echt auf den Keks.
Nee, das ist absolut valide
als Feedback, das stimmt.
Gab es das nicht sogar beim
Tiny Tiny RSS bei der App?
Kann man glaube ich Touch auch ausmachen und sagen,
benutze nur die
Volume-Tasten zum Hoch- und Runterscrollen.
Witzig.
Das habe ich nie gemacht, aber
das ist zumindest was, was man bedenkt.
Man sagt immer, Touchscreen ist geil, aber eigentlich hat Touchscreen auch große Nacht.
Das stimmt.
Aber dieses New-Sync-Feature habe ich auch mal probiert tatsächlich.
Ich fand es auch ganz cool, aber ich habe mein Kindle so selber beim Rechner synchronisieren wollen,
dass es daran weggestorben ist.
Das Problem ist, ich hätte das gerne einfach von vornherein.
Was es benutzt hat, ist dieses Nachrichtenformat.
Das ist nicht direkt das gleiche wie ein E-Book, sondern es wurde halt auf dem Kindle anders dargestellt.
Du kannst ja auf dem Kindle auch sowas wie die Zeit oder sowas direkt abonnieren.
Und dann hast du genau solche E-Books auf deinen Kindle gekriegt.
Und ich habe schon überlegt, ob man irgendwie, das ging leider nicht,
ich hätte gerne Calibre als Headless Service gehabt,
dass ich das auf einem Raspberry Pi habe,
dass das irgendwie einmal nachts anspringt und so einen Sündlauf macht
und sich dann wieder beendet und das Gerät trennt.
So könntest du das, hätte ich dir überlegt,
könntest du das Ding über USB an dein Pi anschließen
und nachts daran laden lassen.
Und dann hat es das Ding direkt vollgespielt mit neuen Sachen.
Bei Wireless Sync mit dem Kindle ist ja kein Problem.
Das gibt es ja schon seit Urzeiten des Kindles,
dass du Dinge an eine E-Mail-Adresse schickst
und die auf dem Kindle eben landen.
Das Problem ist eben,
eben Calibre zu starten
und den Kram halt runterzuladen,
zu formatieren.
Ich habe auch kein Amazon-Account aktiviert gehabt.
Achso, das habe ich eben drauf.
Das ist halt blöd,
weil die dann eben Dinge löschen können.
Bei dem Kindle,
es gab schon eine geile Hexe.
Es gab doch mal einen Kindle
mit GPS
oder zumindest mit Mobilfunk.
Das hatte ich,
weil mein erstes Kind hatte Mobilfunk.
Wir hatten auch wie einen extra Deal
mit den Mobilfunkherstellern gehabt,
dass du überall Internet hast,
weil es macht ja nicht viel.
das war halt irgendwie geschützt, aber dieser Kindle
hatte halt überall mobilen Internetzugang
und zwar unbegrenzt. Da gab es wirklich Leute, die das Ding
einigermaßen aufgebaut hatten, um dann
den Kindle dann als
mobiles Modem zu benutzen.
Die hatten eine Begrenzung, du hattest
eine SIM-Karte drin, die war bezahlt von Amazon,
du hast quasi einen kleinen Aufbreit beim Kauf des Geräts
gezahlt, um das eben zu decken. Was du überall
durftest, war der Amazon-Store und
Wikipedia. Das durftest du überall auf der
Welt nutzen, aber freie Internet nicht.
Ach so, also war es eher so ein Zero-Rating-
Angebot. Genau.
Ich meine, es ist logisch, dass sie
sich zur Amazon eben durchlassen, damit du denen eben Geld geben kannst,
um Bücher zu kaufen. Aber ich fand es auch
damals recht cool, dass ich tatsächlich Wikipedia
im Urlaub auch nutzen konnte, wenn ich gerade
irgendwo sonst wo saß. Aber du durftest nicht
ins Freien Internet damit.
Das war abgespeckt
ein bisschen. Aber
naja. Heutzutage verkaufen sie dir ja auch
ein Kindle, was Werbung auf dem Lockscreen anzeigt.
Billiger. Ja. Das habe
ich tatsächlich aus Versehen. Mein aktuelles Kindle
ist so ein Gerät gekauft. Ja, da steht
aber auch, du kannst jetzt hier bezahlen, um
diese Werbung abzuschalten. Ja, ich habe es halt
aus Versehen gekauft, ohne es zu merken, weil
ich habe halt nicht genau hingeschaut.
Ich hätte die Werbung auch nicht so sehr gestört, muss ich sagen,
wenn ich nicht dann beim Unlock
immer nur auf den Knopf, beim typischen
Kind-Unlock drückst du auf den Knopf und das war's,
bei dem Werbekinder drückst du auf den Knopf und dann musst du auf dem Display
swipen. Und das hat mich angekotzt
und dann habe ich den mit dem Support eben angerufen und der meinte,
ja, ist ja bald Weihnachten, ich schalte das jetzt einfach mal raus.
Das fand ich recht nett. Also ich musste
nichts zahlen dafür, das fand ich
angenehm. Das ist natürlich
Schön. Genau, den letzten
Kitab-Sahle-Woche, um nochmal zurückzukommen,
was ich mir noch aufgeschrieben habe, ist
CoWim, das ist ein Wim-Plugin,
was dir die Möglichkeit bietet,
Collaborative Editing in Wim eben zu haben.
Und dann kannst du dich mit einer Session connecten
in deinem Wim und
dann sind da mehrere Cursor in verschiedenen Farben
und wir können mehrere Leute gleichzeitig schreiben,
das ist quasi ein Etherpad in Wim,
in der langen Liste der coolen Wim-Plugins,
die wahrscheinlich niemand nutzt, mal noch was
hinzuzufügen. Dann schaut es euch ja mal an,
ist witzig. Wir hatten eine komische Voraussetzung,
dass man ein mit Python 2.5
kompiliertes WIM braucht.
Oder mehr. Nicht, ich bitte das, aber
brauchst du. Na ja, klar, du kannst ja
WIM-Plugins in dieser komischen WIM-Sprache
oder in Python bauen.
Bei NeoWIM haben sie, glaube ich, dann angefangen,
es komplett durch Lua zu ersetzen
und WIM-Skript rauszunehmen.
Okay. Das war so eines der Features.
Aber ja, es ist auch komisch,
dass du halt, du kannst, glaube ich, auch
WIM-Plugins in Ruby schreiben. Das ist alles ein bisschen
eklig. Auch nicht.
Naja, ich meine, es ist
so ein Editor, dass du den erweiterbar machst,
ist schon sinnvoll im Endeffekt.
Dadurch ermöglichst du ja ganz viele Sachen.
Und wenn man genau darüber nachdenkt,
E-Mex ist ja nur,
da ist ja der Editor nur ein Anwendungsfall
für dieses Software Development Kit,
was eigentlich auf Lisp basiert
und was Leute dann daraus gebaut haben,
also sich E-Mail-Clients, Kalender, To-Do-Apps,
alles Mögliche innerhalb von E-Mex,
war eigentlich, damit war eigentlich E-Mex
der erste Vorgänger von
sowas, was heute Elektron ist.
Das stimmt eigentlich, ja.
Du hast eine Umgebung, du kannst ein bisschen GUI damit machen,
du hast eine Skriptsprache, mit der du eine Anwendung
bauen kannst. Ein und für sich ist Elektron
E-Max für JavaScript.
Kumpel von mir,
ich bin auch, chattet immer über Telegram
aus dem E-Max Plug-in
heraus oder E-Max Tool.
Add-On, wie auch immer die heißen dann.
Er mag das.
Ja, und in Wim kannst du halt Erweiterungen in Wim-Skript schreiben
und dann irgendwann haben sich Leute gedacht, Wim-Skript ist nicht schön,
bauen wir mal Python ein und irgendwann haben sich Leute gedacht,
naja, eigentlich ist Lua dafür angemessener,
also machen wir mal Lua und plötzlich gab es mehrere Sachen
gleichzeitig und irgendwann hat auch noch irgendjemand
Rubi eingebaut. Da kannst du einfach so den Weg gehen,
dass du quasi irgendein Interface
freigibst und Leute schreiben können, was immer sie wollen.
Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn man mittlerweile
FIM-Plugins nicht auch in JavaScript
schreiben kann.
Ist das nicht so die Idee von diversen
modernen, in Anführungsstrichen, Editoren,
dass die quasi eine Schnitzel
freigeben, auf der du quasi
Server-ähnlich mit
JSON sprechen kannst und dann halt
dein Tool beliebig implementierst
und das... Ja, im Endeffekt macht es das
genauso. Es ist der...
NeoVim hat extra in seiner...
Also NeoVim ist ein Projekt, was Vim nimmt
und aufräumt und
dafür sorgen möchte, dass Vim, was ja schon 20
Jahre alt ist, auch in 20 Jahren
noch aktuell verwendet werden kann.
Der Hauptentwickler von
Vim hat zu gesagt, na gut, okay, wenn du meint,
aber macht ruhig.
Letztes Jahr war
ein Wim-Meeting in Berlin gleichzeitig zum Rust-Fest,
als ich da war.
Da haben die Leute von Neo-Wim und der Haupt-Wim-Entwickler
hier, der, wie heißt der?
Einfach mal Wim aufmachen, da steht sein Name drin.
Der heißt, ne, das Fenster ist zu klein.
Wim, komm, hier.
Ja klar, Brad Mulinau.
Die haben so Sachen eingebaut in Neo-Wim,
was es erweiterbarer machen sollte.
zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit,
dass du Skripte asynchron
ausführen kannst, was ja sehr
schön ist für aufwendige Skripte,
zum Beispiel so ein Compiler-Durchlauf.
Vorher war es so, du hast aus deinem WIM raus
einen Compiler gestartet und musstest ihm halt bis zu Ende
zugucken, bis du den Output davon pausen konntest.
Das geht mittlerweile, seit WIM
8 geht das asynchron, aber
anders als
die Leute von NeoWIM das gebaut hatten,
weil der,
dementsprechend ist NeoWIM nicht wirklich eine Erweiterung
von WIM, sondern es ist so ein bisschen an vielen Stellen
haben sie die gleichen Sachen unterschiedlich
gebaut. Was zum Beispiel auch
in Neo-Wim eingebaut haben, ist
halt eine
kleine Server-Schnittstelle, dass du von außen
mit dem Wim über eine
Message-Pack-Schnittstelle
produzieren kannst. Das ist also nicht Jason,
sondern Message-Pack.
Und was relativ ähnlich ist,
hat halt der Entwickler von diesem
Zy-Editor, diesem
Ray Flavin,
gemacht. Der Editor
ist an und für sich headless, der hat keinen Interfail,
oder das ist jetzt einfach bloß ein Model.
Und du kannst halt von außen über eine JSON-Schnittstelle damit kommunizieren.
Tatsächlich hätte man an der Stelle auch was anderes als JSON nehmen können,
weil JSON ein bisschen teurer ist als zum Beispiel Message Pack oder Proto-Bach.
Das ist ein sehr bekannter Standard, sehr verbreitet.
Ja, theoretisch.
Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass wenn der das in Rust gebaut hat,
dass er dann sinnvollerweise dafür sowas wie Serde nimmt.
Und Serde ist ein generisches Serialisierungs-Deserialisierungs-Framework.
da kannst du dann wahrscheinlich ohne weiteres später
das Transportformat auch mal eben austauschen
und aus JSON Message Pack machen.
Was soll das tun, bevor Leute viele Plugins schreiben?
Ja, und wenn du das Plugin in irgendwas baust,
wo du nicht selber dieses JSON zusammenbaust,
sondern einfach nur sagst, schicke mal eine Nachricht
mit diesem Payload an Zy,
dann kannst du das auch zwischendurch hoffentlich aktualisieren
und austauschen.
Das stimmt.
Aber wenn der halt, also Zy ist ein Editor,
das ist übrigens eine Leserempfehlung,
The Science Behind Ropes.
Gibt es denn keine für Text?
Genau, und das Aufwendige oder das Coole an Sai ist,
dass der ein anderes Modell oder ein modernes Modell verwendet,
um Text intern zu speichern.
Du möchtest ja, wenn du einen Text-Detitor baust,
hast du nicht nur einen langen String,
der dein String pro Zeile ist.
Und nicht einfach ein String pro Zeile,
sondern du möchtest ja an einzelnen Stellen,
möchtest du ja was ranschreiben können.
Also fangen wir mal einfach an.
Du hast einen Editor, da schreibst du Text rein.
Dann möchtest du Zeilen vielleicht haben,
damit du an Zeilen springen kannst
oder damit du in Zeilen
zwischen zwei Zeilen was hinzufügen kannst.
Also sagen wir mal, du hast ein Array von Zeilen.
Das reicht aber nicht,
weil du möchtest eventuell
eine Programmiersprache darin darstellen
und dann möchtest du Keywords highlighten.
Dann möchtest du wissen, wo ist ein Keyword.
Das Keyword ist jetzt zum Beispiel,
wenn du anfängst mit Import ganz oben,
Dann hast du Zeile 1 ganz am Anfang.
Das erste Wort ist Import.
Gut, okay, dann merkst du dir Zeilen und Wörter.
Und der Indiz ist in den Zeilen, klar.
Dann hast du aber das Problem,
dass du zwischen Wörtern was hinzufügst.
Dann hast du einfach ein Array von Arrays von Wörtern.
Und jetzt möchtest du dort zwischendurch die ganze Zeit was hinzufügen.
Was machst du jetzt bei einem Array?
Bei einem Array fügst du an Stelle 5 was hinzu
und musst alles hintendran neu allozieren.
auch kacke.
Also hast du eigentlich,
wenn du es dynamisch sauber machen möchtest,
hast du irgendwann eine komplexe
Baumstruktur von einzelnen Sachen,
wo du einfach Sachen einhängst, die dann
flexibler sind.
Und das ist bei
Sai sind das Robes. Also es sind keine
Strings, mit denen du arbeitest, sondern Robes.
Und da gibt es einen Lesetipp von mir,
auch an mich selbst, weil ich das auf irgendeiner Liste
geschrieben habe, aber nicht gelesen habe. Deswegen auch dieses
Gestatter.
The Science Behind Ropes.
Und das ist einfach so eine Reihe von Blogposts
aufgetappt als Gists
von Ralph Levine über
das Textmodell von
Sci.
Dann mit an Future Hendrick, schau mal in die Shownotes und klick den Link an
und lass dich mal durch.
Ich glaube, Future Hendrick, der diese Folge
dann in der Straßenbahn
nochmal querhört,
Probe hört, wird dann sein
Browser aufmachen und als Tab Nummer
Über Cap-Management sollten wir mal reden.
Das wäre wirklich mal ein Thema.
Das können wir nämlich beide nicht.
Wollen wir jetzt noch mit anfangen?
Nein, Platz das Schiemen auf.
Ich würde sagen, wir kommen jetzt mal quasi auch langsam wieder zum Ende hier.
Ja, also wir hätten noch für nächstes Mal,
können wir dann noch ein bisschen über die Themen reden,
die jetzt noch übrig geblieben sind.
Was haben wir noch übrig?
Versionsschemen.
Ach so, du willst das wirklich richtig aufrollen.
Ich wollte einfach nur ein paar witzige Modelle halt.
Also auf das Thema,
Software hat Versionen.
Wie sind wir auf dieses Thema gekommen? Achso, ja,
ich habe Typora, diesen
Markdown-Hitator aufgemacht
und du kriegst ab und zu mal ein Update und
wundernst dich darüber, dass die Version 0.9.9.9.9.4.2 ist.
Und da habe ich gewundert,
ob die sich asymptotisch an 1.0
annähern wollen und dementsprechend nie dort ankommen
und einfach immer mehr 0.9 hinzufügen.
Oder ist keine Ahnung.
Es gibt ja wirklich, normalerweise bei Libraries
oder so, möchtest du dich an Semantic Version
hängen halten. Das ist ein Konzept, das ist noch relativ neu,
würde ich behaupten.
Das ist festgenagelt worden.
Es gibt
semware.org, da ist das wohl
definiert und das sagt
einfach aus,
du hast drei Stellen in deiner
Version, du hast Major Version,
Minor Version und Patch.
Und die Aussage
ist einfach, wenn ich
an der Minor Version was ändere,
dann ist
die Version noch kompatibel, aber
potenzielle Funktionen hinzugekommen.
Wenn ich eine Major-Version was ändere,
dann muss ich als Verwender dieser
Library, es wird hauptsächlich für Libraries
verwendet. In anderen Kontexten auch keinen Sinn ergibt.
Mit Breakage rechnen.
Und bei Patch
weiß ich, dass zwar ein Fix stattgefunden hat,
aber die API der Library
noch exakt genauso aussehen soll.
Genau.
Das wurde eine lange Zeit
ein ähnliches dreistelliges
Konzept von
Firefox oder von anderen
Obsource-Anwendungen verwendet.
Da ist es dann häufig so üblich, dass die erste,
die Major-Version 0 ist.
Das ist sogar in Semware so
standardisiert. Ist es das wirklich?
Ja, und zwar, wenn du noch nicht Version 1.0
erreicht hast, wenn du
unterhalb von 1 bist, dann gelten andere
Regeln. All bets are off.
Genau, dann hast du nämlich diese Stabilitätsregeln,
die du,
die für meiner Version
gelten nicht. Deswegen fange ich quasi
alle meine Projekte auch immer mit Version 0.1.0
Genau, das ist bei Rust-Projekten Standard,
wenn du neue anlegst, wenn du mit NPM
ein neues Node-Projekt erzeugst,
fängst du immer automatisch mit Version 1.0 an,
was ein bisschen blöd ist, weil dann bist du halt
relativ schnell bei Version 15.
Bei dieser
Node-Fair-Rust-Version,
die ich gebaut habe, habe ich mich geärgert, dass ich so schnell
mir gesagt habe, komm jetzt machen wir
Version 1.0, es ist soweit fertig.
Dann kam halt jemand mit einem
Pull-Request und hat was geändert.
Dann war es nicht mehr kompatibel, dann war es plötzlich Version 2.0
und dann kam noch jemand anderes mit einem anderen
Pull-Request, was auch nochmal, oder dann hätte ich das mir noch
was eingefallen und dann musste ich nochmal an der API
was verändern, dann war es Version 3.0,
das ist schon ein bisschen eklig.
Dann hast du halt den Fehler,
du hast halt den Fehler begangen und angefangen
ideellen Wert an die Version mit anzuheften
und dann muss man sich einfach verabschieden
an der Stelle von. Andere Projekte machen es so,
die sagen, okay, ich bin jetzt bei Version
0.15.3
oder so und da habe ich
jetzt schon leider nichts mehr dran verändert
und wir möchten ja irgendwie auch eine Versprechung
machen, du möchtest nicht, also jedes Mal, wenn ich was sehe,
wo eine Nullfunk steht, denke ich mir,
das möchte ich endlich nicht verwenden. Deswegen
gibt es viele Projekte in der
Rust-Library-Welt, die dann
gesagt haben, so, die Version,
zum Beispiel die Regex-Library,
die haben wir jetzt schon ein halbes Jahr
oder nicht mehr verändert,
insofern, dass die Version
stabil geblieben ist, das können wir
jetzt uns, glaube ich, langsam trauen, eine 1.0
rauszubringen. Ich glaube, so ist das ganz in Ordnung.
Man sollte vor dem Schritt
zur 1.0 sollte man schon
vorsichtig machen und auch lieber einfach mal eine Runde warten,
auch nicht noch irgendwas, also es sollte schon eine Weile in Benutzung sein, was du da machst,
bevor du 1.0 rausbringst. Und dann sollte man aber tatsächlich auch irgendwann eine 1.0
rausbringen, damit du einfach eine Garantie dafür gibst,
dass du jetzt hier eine Library hast, die den Status
1.0 auch erreicht hat, weil du möchtest auch eine Aussage darüber treffen,
dass es einen bestimmten Zustand Fertigkeitsgrad erreicht.
Na klar, das ist ja auch völlig valide am Anfang,
sich noch nicht klar zu sein,
wie die API eigentlich fertig aussehen soll und so weiter.
Deswegen finde ich es bei bestimmten Libraries,
also bei Elm-Libraries und bei JavaScript-Libraries,
wenn du da neue erzeugst,
dann fängst du halt automatisch mit 1.0 an
und das ist eigentlich nicht in Ordnung.
Wenn du schon Elm ansprichst,
da wollte ich eh gleich drauf kommen,
Elm macht nämlich noch ein cooles Feature hinzu,
die entforcen auch mit, dass du dich an Semper hältst.
Wenn du mit Elm eine neue Version publishen möchtest
und sagst jetzt hier, ich möchte da jetzt die Miner-Version,
Ich meine, es ist so,
ich bestimme trotzdem die Version und sage,
ich inkrementiere hier meine Version
und versuche das zu publishen. Dann wird nochmal gecheckt,
habe ich tatsächlich eine kompatible API
und wenn ich das nicht habe, kommt da tatsächlich
das Ding mir in die Quere und sagt,
nee, tut mir leid, du musst jetzt hier die Major Version inkrementieren,
bevor du das publishen darfst. Unglaublich cool.
Sowas ähnliches gibt es mittlerweile auch für Rust.
Ich habe selber...
Wolltest du es nicht mal machen? Genau. Ich wollte das mal
als Diplomarbeit machen.
Ich habe mich mittlerweile damit beschäftigt, du kannst ja quasi,
wenn du den
AST, den du deiner Sprache angucken kannst,
kannst du entscheiden,
ist das
Public Interface
von dieser Library noch
identisch zu der vorherigen Version?
Und wenn nicht, ist was dazugekommen oder hat sich
etwas verändert oder ist etwas weggegangen? Eigentlich musst du bloß schauen,
ist es größer oder gleich?
Dann ist es kompatibel.
Und wenn sich was verändert hat, wenn irgendwas
weggegangen ist oder sich verändert hat,
dann geht es nicht mehr.
Swift hat es tatsächlich auch in dem Swift Package Manager
mit drin als Idee für die Zukunft,
seitdem es Open Source geworden ist.
Würde mich freuen, wenn das irgendwann mit auftaucht.
Zusammen mit, die wollten auch noch krassen Kram machen
und automatisch mit deine
License anschauen, sprich wenn du eine Dependency reinziehst,
deren License inkompatibel mit deiner
License ist, dann wird das nicht funktionieren,
beziehungsweise du müsstest es manuell overriden.
Finde ich witzig, dass die solche krassen Features
haben.
Vor allem, dass sie dir halt dadurch
darüber was vorschreiben.
Es gibt für die meisten
Paketmanagers oder Tools, die über deine ganzen
Dependencies drüber gehen und dir deine Liste
mit allen Libraries, die du da drin verwendest,
auflösten. Wo ist ja gerade
das Licensing in der iOS-Welt
schwierig, weil GPL halt absolut
inkompatibel mit dem App Store ist.
Und deswegen Leute, die
unter GPL Libraries
veröffentlichen, die kannst du halt komplett wieder vergessen.
Die kannst du halt nicht für ein iOS-Projekt reinziehen.
Das ist halt ekelhaft.
Aber solche Sachen wollen dir halt damit helfen, dass du da nicht
automatisch in irgendwelche blöden Sachen reinwennst.
Bei Rust war es sogar so, dass
es irgendwann mal jemand, ein Bot
auf die ganzen Repos, der
auf Crates.io
veröffentlichten Libraries losgelassen hat
und dir ein Issue geschrieben hat, wenn du nicht
eine
MIT Apache 2
Lizenz verwendet hast.
Die meisten Crates sind
MIT Apache 2
gedual licenced.
Und er hat dir dann ein Issue geschrieben
und in dem Issue
musste dann jeder Contributor
also konnte, du wurdest
mit einem länglicheren Text darauf hingewiesen,
dass es doch schön wäre, wenn du das machen würdest,
wenn du das re-licensen würdest. Damit du das
aber machen konntest, musste jeder, der
Code kontributet hat, jeder, der
das hat der Bot auch noch rausgesucht,
ganzen Contributor wurden namentlich erwähnt,
da wurde so eine Checkliste reingeschrieben,
und dann musste jeder drunter schreiben,
I hereby re-license
every current and future
or past, bla bla bla,
contribution
under this license.
Ja klar, musst du ja so machen. Du kannst ja nicht einfach
was relicensen, wenn die Contributor
nicht agree, die haben ja auch kommt und reingeschrieben.
Wenn du der Einzige bist, der bisher diese Library geschrieben hat,
dann kannst du machen, was du brächtest.
Aber es wird halt schwierig, wenn andere Leute
damit reinschreiben. Das sollte man
schon beachten. Warum wir eigentlich
diese Thematik hier mit der Versionierung mal ansprechen
wollten, weil wir noch vorhin mal
wieder über die Versionsnummer von
LaTeX gestolpert sind, die sich halt immer
weiter Pi ernährt, bis zu dem Punkt,
nee, Tech ist das, die Tech-Versionsnummer.
Tech ist nicht Artig. Genau, Tech
nähert sich Pi an, Schritt für Schritt,
mit jeder, wir haben halt eine Zahl hinzu,
mit jeder Version, die halt rauskommt,
und hat halt die witzige Grundregel,
dass sobald Donald Knut
eben leider das Zeitliche segnet,
wird die Version auf gleich Pi
gesetzt, also wirklich dem Wert von Pi,
und ist damit fertig und darf nicht mehr verändert
werden. Tech Pi?
Tech Pi? Tech Pi.
Also die Version ist dann...
Nicht Tech 3.13,
sondern Tech Pi.
Welches Tech nützt du? TechP natürlich.
Tech nützt ja eh keiner.
Das darf dann auch wirklich nicht mehr weiterentwickelt werden?
Tech ist an der Stelle dann fertig.
Die Leute müssen halt LaTeX. Der Grund, warum LaTeX existiert,
ist, damit Tech
weiterentwickelt werden kann, auch nach dem
Ablehnen von Donald Knuth.
Eigentlich schade. Ich fände es schon
ganz gut, wenn die Leute nochmal sagen, gut, okay, jetzt kann es nicht mehr
weiterentwickelt werden, jetzt können wir uns mal was anderes ausdenken.
Das ist so eine Lebenszeitverschwendung, Tech zu benutzen.
Nicht so schlimm.
Tech ist schon echt gut, weil
gerade creepy Font-Handling geht halt mit
nichts gut, außer Tech.
Anders. Was Tech macht,
ist in Ordnung.
Wie Tech es macht. Gut, gut.
Das unterstreiche ich sofort. Also ich finde es sinnvoll, dass es
auch so eine Layouting-Engine gibt und
das ist irgendwie, aber wie
ich meinen Code in Tech schreibe
und was ich machen muss, um das dazu zu
bringen, irgendwas zu machen
und wie gerade die Sprache,
die oben drauf gesetzt ist, auf Makros basierend,
das ist so fürchterlich.
Aber ist halt auch mächtig.
Ja, es ist mächtig, aber guck dir mal an, wie du
du schreibst, Section, Subsection,
Sub-Subsection, Sub-Sub-Subsection.
Das gibt es schon gar nicht mehr.
Die dritte Ebene muss selber erzucht,
die existiert von außen.
Dann gibt es Big, Large, Huge,
Huge in Capitals.
Das ist einfach flüchterlich.
Die Syntax ist schrecklich, da stimme ich dir sofort zu.
Also ich fände es eher sinnvoll,
wenn man irgendwie von,
und das gibt es ja, wenn man von
Markdown oder irgendwas Einfacherem
oder HTML mit CSS
danach pipen könnte.
Also ist quasi Markdown das CoffeeScript für Tech
und das jagst dann mal durch Pendock durch.
Du hast ja in deinem Projekt,
also es ist ja gut,
wenn du, jetzt gehe ich schon wieder
auf das nächste Thema ein, aber gut, wo wir
einmal dabei sind, du möchtest halt,
wenn du ein Dokument schreibst, sagen wir mal so eine Diplomarbeit
zum Beispiel,
dann erlernst du dich halt mit LaTeX rum.
Das sollte überhaupt nicht dein Problem sein. Du solltest
Text runterschreiben. Du möchtest natürlich die Vorteile
von LaTeX haben, aber
diese Durchmischung von Inhalt und
Code ist halt fürchterlich. Ne, die Durchmischung
von Inhalt und Format ist immer das Problem.
Und das hast du auch in LaTeX eigentlich weniger,
als wenn du zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, in Word schreibst.
In LaTeX ist die Grundidee, du schreibst erstmal
deinen Text runter und das war's. Und am Ende
kümmerst du dich halt um das bisschen Formatting-Fu,
was du halt dazwischen oder hauptsächlich davor wirst.
Du kannst nicht einfach deinen Text runter schreiben.
Du hast zum Beispiel, wenn du Listen hast, wenn du Header hast,
wenn du Subsections hast, schreibst du immer LaTeX-Code.
Du hast ein bisschen Struktur, okay, das sehe ich ein,
die musst du mit reinpacken, aber du sollst es auf
Beginns itemize, end itemize
und dann diese komische Backslash-Syntax
mit item, item, item.
Ja gut, dann nutzt Markler an der Stelle und konvertiert mit Pandoc
zu Tech. Ja, so habe ich es gemacht.
Es ist halt schon irgendwie
wie Klammern
in LaTeX
Makros verwendeter werden. Das ist irgendwie
nicht konsistent.
Und dann hast du
Sachen, die sich gegenseitig beeinflussen.
Das ist okay.
Typische LaTeX-Syntax.
Aber ich sage dir ja, das Kerning
super. Das sind eigentlich die Sachen,
die gehen halt nirgendwo anders gut.
Aber trotzdem hast du dann
manchmal
seltsames Verhalten, dass du plötzlich
Leerseiten oder halbe Leerseiten drin stehen hast.
Irgendwie Sachen, die dann trotzdem aus deinem
Blogsatz rausbrechen, weil sie nicht anders
gelandert werden konnten.
Und dann kommst du wieder jemanden,
der dann ein bisschen Hilfe sucht und du erklärst dem erstmal,
dass er hier mit
Hurenkindern und
Schusterjungen und Huren...
Söhne. Ne, die heißen nicht Huren, Söhne.
Das ist die Beleidigung. Schusterjungen und
Hurenkinder, glaube ich, sind die Bezeichnungen in der
Typesetting-Welt für Sätze,
die halt auf einer Seite anfangen,
Absätze, die auf einer Seite mit einem Satz anfangen, beziehungsweise
mit einem Teilsatz halt noch auf einer Seite weitergehen.
Genau. Das war neulich in einem
knappen Quiz mal eine Frage.
Aus welcher Welt kommen Hurenkinder
und Schusterjungen?
Genau, Typesetting. Das immer wieder.
Aber ich würde sagen, damit machen wir auch wirklich langsam
mal Schluss für heute. Wir haben genug gesprochen.
Wir sind auch wieder bei zwei Stunden.
Ach du Scheiße, wie schnell sind wir?
Wir haben das komplette Ende vom Mobile Camp
mit hier quasi vor unseren Augen
abspielen lassen. Vorhin war noch
voll Mobile Camp, als wir angefangen haben und jetzt ist
quasi fertig aufgeräumt. Ja, hier fährt
gerade ein Vater seinen kleinen
Toddler mit so einer Sackkarre
durch das Fliege.
Mit einer Sackkarre? Das sieht bestimmt ein bisschen witziger aus.
Ja, das müsste hier halt so ein Schubwagen.
Aber gut, es ist jetzt
noch nicht mal 18 Uhr. Ist eigentlich
in Ordnung. Sonne scheint noch. Ich glaube, ich gehe noch ein bisschen
Longboard fahren. Machen wir das. Dann beenden wir mit der
Folge. Ihr habt mal wieder eine Folge Akronomisierbar
Folge 5. Wir sind Kilian und
Hendrik. Diesmal sagen wir jeder unseren eigenen Namen.
Verdammt, haben wir das anders gemacht.
Ihr findet uns auf Twitter unter dem
Handel
bzw. ich bin Kilian Koe
mit einem L.
Du bist at hoodie-de.
Ihr könnt uns abonnieren auf iTunes,
Bitlove, Füt, was auch immer.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao.